bonjour à toutes et à tous le
si j'ai bien compris donc la
présentation aujourd'hui elle inaugure
un cycle qui s'appelle approche
systémique et politiques publiques et il
est question aujourd'hui de vous parler
du territoire francilien ils vont finir
là je fais un tout petit peu débordé de
mon mandat quand même et vous parler d'
approche systémique et de politiques
publiques justes
au début je sais qu'elle a d'elle on
aime bien gore ce dont je vais ouvrir
avec un petit dessin degorce une fois je
vous ai dit ça vous pouvez aller prendre
un café parce que je vous ai résumé le
lien que du haut de mes maintenant 56
ans j'ai constaté pendant vingt-cinq ou
trente ans sur la relation entre le
pouvoir politique et n'importe quelle
démarche rationnelle intelligente
n'importe laquelle
dit autrement moi je crois je sais
surtout je suis investie de la
légitimité des urnes
vous vous êtes le technocrate là qui n'a
aucune légitimité parce que je sais pas
d'où vous sortez donc je vous demande de
faire et vous faites et si le
technocrate lève le doigt en disant
monsieur ce que vous me demandez où
madame récemment ce que vous me demandez
n'a ni queue ni tête c'est tétouan
dehors va voir ailleurs si j'y suis
exécuté fonctionnaires moi j'ai la
légitimité démocratique
donc on va se faire plaisir cet après
midi je suis un tout petit peu
désagréable en entrée je pense que ça
n'aura que très peu d'influencé sur les
promesses totalement farfelue qui vont
continuer d'abonder dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons
ça va avoir malheureusement extrêmement
peu d' influence parce que le processus
qui amène la surenchère électorale est
un processus qui est déconnecté de la
réalité des faits d'accord c'est un
processus déconnecté de la réalité des
faits en plus la réalité des faits
deuxième truc très désagréable que je
vais dire en entrée c'est qu'elle n'est
pas exactement celle qu'on pense tout le
temps
vous avez ici un les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ou simplement les
émissions de co2 par dollar de valeur
ajoutée c'est-à-dire par dollars de pib
que nous avons en europe sur les 50
dernières années donc vous voyez que en
europe sur les 50 dernières années comme
nous sommes connus pour être un
continent extrêmement écolo avec des
politiques publiques extrêmement féroce
en faveur de
nous avons divisé par un facteur 3 la
quantité de co2 par dollar de piles 50
ans alors après on va voir des gens qui
sont connus pour n'avoir strictement
aucune politique publique en matière
d'environnement et on constate que on a
divisé par trois les émissions de co2
par dollar de pipe alors ça vous fait
rire ou ça vous fait pleurer
selon les jours etc mais ça questionne
commeinhes très fortement la question de
savoir quelle est la part des tambours
inad sur le poitrail en expliquant c'est
à cause de ma politique publique
intelligente que les choses se sont
passées quand vous voyez ça vous pouvez
très sincèrement vous poser la question
de savoir est ce que la politique
publique dans cette histoire
elle précède l'action où elle revendique
un truc qui arrive pour des raisons qui
n'ont strictement rien à voir avec la
politique publique est derrière vous
fait un très beau paquet cadeau dans
lequel vous habiller le truc en vous
attribuant des mérites qui ne sont
absolument pas les vôtres
et là aussi je peux être vous paraître
un peu cynique ou caustique mais mon
expérience personnelle c'est que dans ce
que j'ai pu observer jusqu'à maintenant
vous avez 20 conscient du premier 80% du
deuxième grosse maille je vais vous
donner un autre exemple toujours avec
des courbes vous avez ici
la quantité de co2 par kilowatts heure
d'énergie primaire en allemagne alors je
rappelle que l'énergie primaire c'est
l'énergie qu'on prélève dans
l'environnement par opposition à
l'énergie finale qui est celle que l'on
donne à manger aux machines dans pas
longtemps
donc c'est la quantité de co2 sur
l'ensemble de la consommation
énergétique de l'allemagne c'est à dire
charbon gaz pétrole nucléaire éolien etc
je vous aime volontairement masqué
l'échelle des abscisses là donc
maintenant je vais faire un petit
sondage dans la salle qui pensent que le
début de la transition énergétique
allemande c'est la personne qui pense
que c'est la non qui pensent que c'est
là
qui pense que c'est là qu'ils pensent
que c'est là
bon vous voyez vous avez la réponse
la réponse c'est que c'est au début de
la flèche en gros c'est milieu des
années 90 fin des années 90 donc ce que
vous dit ce graphique c'est que si vous
regardez l'évolution en séries longues
de la quantité de co2 émise par
kilowatts heure d'énergie primaire ont
par tonne équivalent pétrole d'énergie
primaire en allemagne vous n'êtes pas
foutu de savoir à quel moment une
politique publique qui leur a quand même
coûté 300 milliards d'euros à ce jour
ils s'en foutent ils ont 200 milliards
de soit des spectateurs par an donc ils
peuvent s'ils ont envie de se payer
cette danseuse a pas de problème mais ça
leur a coûté 300 milliards et vous êtes
un foutu en regardant cette courbe de
savoir à quel moment ça a commencé en
fait ça on n'en a pas eu ça n'en a pas
eu d'effet disruptif sur les émissions
de co2 en fait quand vous regardez je
vous ai je vous promets que je vous mets
pas la cour mais quand vous regardez les
émissions de co2 par type d'énergie en
allemagne ce qui a baissé le plus vite
depuis la milieu de milieu des années 90
et le pétrole il n'a strictement rien à
voir avec la production électrique qui
n'a absolument rien à voir donc si vous
regardez la france d'autant les français
beaucoup s'auto flageller m'enfin de
temps en temps on a aussi le droit de
dire du bien de ce compte de ce qu'on
fait d'interdît eh bien vous voyez que
pour une valeur en euros de 2016
jusqu'en euros de 1973 ce n'était pas la
même chose mais en euros de 2016 qui
vaut à peu près le même montant de
grandeur là vous avez quand même un
effet discernable sur les émissions de
co2 par kilowattheure utilisés en france
donc la politique publique
dans cette histoire il ya c'est très
très difficile de savoir évaluer ses
mérites effectifs alors l'approchent
systémique c'est facile de vous décrire
ce que c'est on va en parler dans pas
longtemps
mais par contre de savoir si elle a le
moindre effet en fait si tout un petit
ou de construction intelligente a le
moindre effet sur les politiques
publiques et si les politiques unique
elle même ont le moindre effet sur ce
qui se passe ça ces deux étages de la
fusée qui sont
l'objet de beaucoup plus de discussions
et dans notre pays ou on aime pas le
contrôle de gestion de faire le bilan ex
post ou le post mortem de des mesures
qui ont été prises pour voir si
effectivement ça servait à quelque chose
un truc qu'on n'aime pas trop faire
d'accord quand on fait voilà donc et
puis alors on a comme je disais tout à
l'heure à un problème qui est que la
politique publique se ressemblent trop
souvent à ça d'accord
alors ça c'est la malédiction de la
démocratie expliqué tocqueville parce
que vous faire élire en expliquant vous
allez faire moins bien que le voisin
c'est compliqué d'accord à partir du
moment où vous et lisez les gens par
acclamation très très compliqué de dire
votez pour moi et votre pouvoir d'achat
va baisser
vous pouvez essayer marche pas bien
c'est très compliqué de dire votez pour
moi et vous aller transpirer un grand
coup et vous allez avoir des nerfs mais
vous allez y laisser 20% votre pouvoir
d'achat compliqué donc en pratique ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui ses 100 d'accord
alors y'a pas de problème
allons-y le pib va augmenter mais dans
le même temps on sera un autre en 2050
il y aura plus un tout le monde aura
accès à la bagnole mais elles sont tout
électrique 100% vénère donc la maison
qui organise pas les mêmes
sympa vous explique dans l'électricité
et puis dans le gaz il n'y a pas le
moindre problème
arnaud costes et dur est derrière la loi
de transition énergétique on a rajouté
pour la croissance verte
voilà moi je sais pas pourquoi verte des
versé 5 % de l'électorat on aurait pu
faire la croissance bleu blanc rouge
ça c'était 100 % des lecteurs
donc on est en termes de politiques
publiques je viens de vous expliquer que
si vous prenez un regard historique
c'est à dire si vous faites le post
mortem de ce qui s'est déjà passé vous
avez un nombre incalculable d'exemples
où par ailleurs il ya des gens qu'on
racontait des trucs intelligents ou même
moment et ça n'a pas eu le moindre effet
sur ce qui s'est passé
alors en fait je vais vous proposer un
proxy pour l'emprunt pour l'impact en
cela un environnement qui s'appelle
l'énergie et en fait j'ai voulu proposer
pour une très bonne raison c'est que
l'énergie c'est
non pas contrairement à ce qui vient à
l'esprit de tout le monde quand on parle
d'énergie ou une facture ou l'objet d'un
débat l'énergie c'est avant tout une
grandeur physique qui a le bon goût de
caractériser le changement du monde qui
nous entoure
c'est quand même bien parce que si on
veut quantifier l'impact qu'on a sur
l'environnement on a une grandeur à
notre disposition
j'appelle l'énergie qui quantifie
l'impact qu'on a sur l'environnement
puisque cela quantifie la transformation
de l'environnement
c'est ça la définition de l'énergie donc
l'énergie avant d'être l'objet de
savants débat dans notre pays pour
lesquels en général les résultats sont
écrits à l'avancé
je vous signale que en entrée du dn théo
il y avait la promesse électorale de
hollande de faire 50% de nucléaire dans
l'électricité donc ont sorti du tnt oeil
a dit c'est vachement bien de faire 50%
de nucléaire dans l'électricité nos
surprises
et là je peux vous dire que en entrée du
débat sur la ppe
du reste on a mis un anti nucléaires à
la tête de la commission particulière du
débat public pour être sûr que c'est
bien ça qu'on aurait vous aurez le fait
que ça serait quand même vachement bien
de baisser le nucléaire dans
l'électricité
voilà j'ai vécu ce genre de truc de
l'intérieur donc je peux vous dire que
le résultat est écrit à l'avancé
tout simplement parce que un élu n'a pas
la compétence technique donc le ministre
de du moment il n'y a pas la compétence
technique pour savoir exploiter la
matière qui seraient laissés par les
contributions intelligente parce qu'en
plus il faut savoir faire le tri pour
être capable derrière de faire un truc
remontant donc consensuelle avec sa
cohérence interne
en fait c'est impossible de faire un
truc remontant avec sa cohérence interne
ça n'existe pas quand vous faites un
truc cohérent on fait des choix quand
vous faites des choix ou fait des
perdants donc un truc remontant qui a sa
cohérence interne
c'est juste impossible donc donc
l'énergie cse qui quantifie l'impact sur
l'environnement c'est sa définition
d'accord c'est sa définition en fait la
définition de l'énergie c'est la
transformation d'un système c'est ce qui
quantifie la transformation d'un système
l'énergie elle est régie par un certain
nombre de lois en particulier il ya deux
grandes lois qui régissent l'énergie qui
sont les deux principes de la
thermodynamique dont le premier est très
très simple on l'appelle aussi la loi de
conservation de l'énergie et ce premier
principe de la thermodynamique dit un
truc d'une simplicité biblique mais aux
conséquences terribles
ce premier principe dit que dans un
système clos l'énergie se conserve dans
un système clos ni vous ne produisez ni
vous ne détruisent et d'énergie
l'énergie se conserve et elle se
conserve pas à peu près
y'a pas 3% de démarque inconnue non
c'est très exactement conserver ce qui
veut dire que si vous prenez l'humanité
tant que l'humanité n'est pas capable
d'extraire de l'énergie de
l'environnement
elle ne peut rien sortir comme service
d'accord pour que vous ayez une
production effectuées par les hommes
c'est à dire un truc qui sort du système
humain eh bien il faut que vous ayez en
entrée de l'énergie extraite de
l'environnement c'est indispensable
dit autrement utiliser de l'énergie ça
n'est rien faire d'autre que de la
sortir de l'environnement et ensuite de
l'exploiter à notre profit c'est ça
qu'on se met de l'énergie
c'est à sortir de l'environnement or
l'énergie concerne l'environnement
s'appelle de l'énergie primaire
une fois qu'on a fait une première
transformation d'énergie primaire pour
être capable de la mettre dans une
machine parce qu'une machine ne mange
pas du pétrole brut
une machine qui mangent l'électricité
vous en avait pas dans l'environnement
sauf dans les éclairs d'orage ne s'est
pas très commode à utiliser donc vous
avez une transformation dans le système
énergétique d'énergie primaire en
énergie finale et l'énergie finale c'est
ce qui rentre dans une machine sans que
l'électricité qui rentre dans mon
ordinateur c'est d'énergie finale et le
carburant qui rentre dans vos voitures
parce qu'aujourd'hui la sncf et grève
sinon c'est pas bien c'est aussi une
énergie finale c'est parce qu'il sort de
l'environnement alors utiliser de
l'énergie
c'est donc l'extraire de l'environnement
mais une fois que vous l'avez extraites
de l'environnement une fois que vous
avez l'énergie elle sert à rien en tant
que tel donc vous avez sorti du pétrole
de terre une fois vous avez votre
pétrole là pour autant vous n'avez pas
une voiture qui se déplacent pour avoir
une voiture qui se déplace il faut vous
et le pétrole et la voiture et la
voiture en fait c'est un convertisseur
d'énergie donc utiliser de l'énergie
c'est avoir deux ingrédients en main
c'est avoir l'énergie elle même et c'est
avoir un convertisseur qui va être
capable d'utiliser cette énergie pour en
faire autre chose alors historiquement
le seul convertisseur que les hommes ont
eu à leur disposition s'étaient
eux-mêmes
vous vous êtes un convertisseur
d'énergie je suis un convertisseur
d'énergie j'ai mangé à midi je suis
capable de transformer sa move en demies
cordes vocales
je suis aussi capable de transformer ça
en mouvement de mes jambes je suis
capable de transformer sa surtout en
chaleur corporelle qui fait que je me
maintiens à 37° parce que si je passais
à 34 il faudrait que j'aille à l'hôpital
à côté aurait pu causer etc
mais donc on utilise de l'énergie
comprend dans l'environnement
on en fait de la chaleur et du mouvement
et cette énergie qu'on prend dans
l'environnement c'est des trucs qui se
mange encore c'est ça qu'on prendra
environnement prend aussi la chaleur du
soleil en direct soit dit en passant
plus c'est chaud et moi on a besoin de
manger pour assurer sa régulation
thermique puisque nous aussi nous sommes
dit que nous sommes sujets au dg eu
exactement comme les bâtiments d'accord
donc quand il ya moins de délits lui on
a besoin de moins manger c'est pour ça
que vous mangez moins l'été en tout cas
si vous mangez autant poignées d'amour
s'en ressentent donc ce qu'ont ceux
qu'on utilise nous comme énergie c'est
juste des choses qui se mange
et puis watts et papin et leurs petits
copains en fait bien avant même il ya eu
la marine à voile et les moulins à eau
ont découvert qu' on était capable
d'extraire d'autres formes dans
d'énergie de l'environnement mais que
nous ne sommes pas capables d'exploiter
par exemple vous si vous mettez sous une
chute d'eau ça vous confère pas une
aptitude à marteler de la tôle d'accord
si vous vous mettez comment vous a fait
faire dans les cours de récré et là je
suis moins content qu'un moulin à vent
mais je tombe plus vite enfin rappelé si
je vous met dans le vent
ça vous donne pas une aptitude à moudre
du grain d'accord et si je vous fait
boire du pétrole ça vous fera pas
avancer plus vite
donc vous vous n'êtes pas capable de
convertir un certain nombre d' énergie
disponible dans l'environnement pour
lesquelles les ingénieurs des temps
anciens ou plus modernes ont été
capables de mettre au point des
convertisseurs qui eux étaient capables
d'exploiter cette énergie donc on a
exploité successivement toutes les
énergies renouvelables qu'on avait avec
disposition donc un monde 100 % ou
vénère oui c'est possible il ya
strictement aucun débat là dessus
c'était la condition humaine ya deux
siècles donc si la condition aux limites
ce que tout le monde accepte ces 500
millions d'agriculteurs 25 ans
d'espérance de vie à la naissance il ya
aucun problème pour refaire un monde
100% venayre aucun problème d'accord si
la condition aux limites ces sept
milliards de terriens dans le pouvoir
d'achat n'a pas baissé alors là je parie
tout mon argent sur le fait qu'on n'y
arrivera jamais 9 heures le monde n'est
pas assez vaste pour ça parce qu'il fait
que 13,8 km de diamètre
mais sinon 100% weider ça pose aucun
problème encore une fois c'est là qu'on
était il ya deux siècles
et puis on a découvert d'autres trucs
voilà on s'est mis à utiliser du charbon
du pétrole du gaz et c'est donc comme
utiliser de l'énergie en fait c'est
mobiliser un convertisseur
ce qu'il faut comprendre maintenant à
chaque fois que je vais parler d'énergie
c'est machine utilisée de plus en plus
d'énergie s'est mobilisée de plus en
plus de machines
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre et c'est
pour ça qu'ils utilisaient de moins en
moins d'énergie c'est très désagréable
ça veut dire se défaire progressivement
d'un certain nombre de machines qui nous
rendent la vie si douce les voitures qui
sont des exosquelettes qui font de nous
superman pour de vrai parce que superman
vol à 120 km/heure quand vous regardez
dans les films et par vous dans une
voiture vous allez vous volez pas si
vous prenez l'avion ou volés plus vite
que superman en fac dans superman vont
aussi vite qu'un avion mais vous êtes
superman pour de vrai grâce à l'énergie
donc l'énergie nous à cause de la donner
à des normes exosquelette alors il n'a
pas la forme d'un homme
enfin sauf que maintenant il ya les
chercheurs de rob hall qui essaye
vraiment lui donner la forme d'un homme
parce qu'ils s'amusent mais sinon ça va
pas la forme d'un homme mais c'est quand
même un énorme exosquelette qui a
augmenté nos capacités d'une bannière
extraordinaire et augmenter nos
capacités c'est augmenter notre
prédation sur l'environnement par
définition augmenter nos capacités
c'est augmenter notre prédation sur
l'environnement alors cette capacité à
mobiliser des machines
la voici donc vous avez ici alors j'ai
laissé le terme consommation encore une
fois c'est un propre et j'en suis désolé
parce que vous ne consommez pas ni la
biomasse voici la biomasse vous
conservez ce qui se mange mais vous
consommez pas du bois enfin pas terrible
si vous mangez de la sciure de bois
vous conservez pas du charbon sauf pour
les flatulences ou ne consommait pas de
pétrole
vous ne mettez pas les doigts dans la
prise électrique fait je vous le
déconseille aussi donc d'une manière
générale vous ne consommez pas l'énergie
donc j'aurais dû barrer et cette légende
là en bas et remplacer sa part capacité
de transformation du monde par personne
plutôt ça que j'aurais dû écrire parce
que c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut lire
lorsque vous voyez c'est que rapporter à
l'individu nous sommes aujourd'hui à un
peu plus de 20000 kilowatts heure par
personne et par an il ya un siècle et
demi on était à peu près à 5000 mais là
dedans l'essentiel c'était de la
biomasse et l'essentiel servait à se
chauffer donc à l'époque la bio c'était
la déforestation du morvan qui
alimentait paris en bois de chauffage
c'était
comment ça et les premières forges qui
avait besoin soit dit en passant d'une
quantité de bois absolument considérable
pour faire un peu de fonte dans des
conditions beaucoup moins efficace que
ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est les
premières machines à vapeur également
mais donc c'est essentiellement ça sert
essentiellement à chauffer ça sert très
peu à faire de la force mécanique
ce que vous voyez c'est que le charbon à
substituer partiellement le bois parce
qu'il servait aussi à se chauffer au
début et puis après il s'est mis à faire
autre chose
la quantité de charbon par personne n'a
jamais décru depuis que on a commencé à
utiliser du charbon donc le charbon
n'est jamais été une énergie du passé ça
a toujours été une énergie de l'avenir
soit dit en passant les français ont
très fortement augmenté leur
consommation de charbon ces quinze
dernières années parce qu'à chaque fois
que vous achetez un truc made in china
vous acheter un truc mayline charbon
donc on consomme des nous les français
je dis bien en consomme pas sur notre
sol mais en consomment beaucoup plus de
charbon aujourd'hui qu'à 15 ans tous vos
smartphones et tous vos ordinateurs il
ya aussi on était made in charbon 500 kg
de co2 çà et là dedans vous devez en
avoir
grosse maille 300 ou 400 qui vient du
charbon donc le charbon aujourd'hui sert
essentiellement à faire de l'électricité
soit les deux tiers du charbon extrait
d'une mine terminent leur vie dans une
centrale électrique
vous voyez que le pétrole n'a pas
remplacer le charbon il est arrivé par
dessus donc le pétrole n'a pas
substituer le charbon tout simplement
parce qu'il sert pas la même chose
le pétrole c'est l'énergie de la
mobilité par excellence le pétrole et
l'énergie qui a la plus grande densité
énergétique par unité de volume de
toutes les énergies que nous manipulons
donc quand vous devez vous déplacer avec
votre énergie que vous emmenez avec vous
cas d'une voiture car d'un bateau au cas
d'un avion c'est le pétrole que vous
allez choisir parce que sarah deux très
loin la plus grande densité énergétique
par unité de poids ou de volume comme
vous voulez
le pétrole c'est 12 kilowatts heure par
kilo les batteries plomb acide de vos
véhicules
c'est 30 watts heure par kilo quand faut
donc 30 kg pour faire un kilowattheure
300 kg pour faire 10 kilowatts heure
rallye de pétrole donc là vous comprenez
pourquoi la voiture électrique a perdu
la partie face à la voiture à pétrole
que les deux ont été en compétition il
ya un siècle et 20 ans et c'est la
voiture à pétrole qui a gagné haut la
main haut la main certes elles avaient
une moindre efficacité de son moteur
mais s'était considérablement plus que
compensé par le fait qu'elle était
capable d'emmener avec l énergie
nécessaire à son déplacement alors
l'avion électrique ça existe ça coûte
300 millions d'euros et ça emmène une
personne bon l'avion à hydrogène ça
existe ça s'appelle la fusée ariane
mais globalement vous n'avez rien de
mieux que le pétrole pour la mobilité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle 98% de ce
qui roule vol ou la vie sur terre
utilisent du pétrole donc le pétrole
c'est l'énergie de la mondialisation
c'est l'énergie de l'étalement urbain
c'est l'énergie des chaînes logistiques
ling et de la spécialisation
industrielle parce que si vous n'avez
pas de chaîne logistique l'on vous
n'êtes pas capables de spécialiser les
activités de manière à ne pas vous êtes
obligés d'avoir tout sur place et donc
des gens polyvalents et moins productifs
par tâche
et puis en angola vous avez ce qui nous
excite en ce moment je vais quand même
rappeler un truc que normalement dans
cette salle vous devriez savoir encore
que mais il n'y a pas le moindre lien
jamais nulle part entre la pagination
d'un sujet dans le journal et son
importance réelle dans le monde
zéro durée s'il y avait un lien si les
journalistes étaient des gens qu'il de
même reflétait ce qui est important dans
le monde des services comme servirait à
rien d'accord le journaliste regarderai
le communiqué de presse en disant je me
fous de ce que tu racontes puisque toute
façon moi je sais ce qui est déjà
important dans le monde je vais parler
de ça donc toi tu es en train de
m'expliquer que tu as sorti un nouveau
produit moi je pense que c'est pas
important que ce qui est important c'est
que y ait un million et demi d'accidents
de gens qui meurent dans des accidents
de voiture dans l'année et je vais
parler de ça en fait non c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe
un journal c'est une gare de triage qui
réagit aux sollicitations externe c'est
pour ça que tous les journaux du 20h
parlent tous de la même chose le même
jour parce qu'ils ont su les mêmes
dépêche issus des mêmes communiqué de
presse donc il faut pas croire une seule
seconde que la presse guérard cheese ce
qu'elle publie en fonction de
l'importance réelle
c'est tout un tas d'autres critères qui
vont être utilisés mais pas ça
il se trouve que quand vous regardez
dans le monde
les variations respectives de chaque
énergie sur les 15 dernières années donc
de combien chaque énergie a augmenté ou
baissé sur les 15 dernières années le
charbon a augmenté 20 fois plus que le
solaire sur les 15 dernières années
donc si la presse reflète l importance
réelle dans le monde pour un article sur
le solaire vous devriez en avoir 20 sur
le charbon pense que vous pouvez
témoigner du fait que c'est pas
exactement ça que vous lisez dans la
presse française
donc je répète il n'y a pas de lien
entre l'importance réelle des processus
dans le monde par contre il ya un lien
entre les motions dans la population et
la pagination dans le journal donc entre
la réaction politique et la pagination
un journal donc si le journal n'arrête
pas de dire que les nerfs c'est
formidable parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont là pour le dire et qu'on a envie de
leur faire dire eh bien le pouvoir
politique dira les nerfs vont résoudre
tous les problèmes et donc je fous le
paquet sur les nerfs et je m'occupe pas
du reste puisque c'est à peu près ce
qu'on est en train de faire en ce moment
en france
voilà la réalité en fait c'est que
l'essentiel de ce qui a permis la
civilisation industrielle c'est des
énergies fossiles et il ya une
excellente raison à ça c'est qu'elles
sont considérablement plus efficace que
les énergies renouvelables pour avoir
des grandes densités de puissance lors
des grandes puissances directement à
disposition les énergies fossiles sont
imbattables
imbattable et aujourd'hui à travers la
machine les machines qui sont la
contrepartie de l'évolution de ces
kilowatt heure là et bien l'humanité a
multiplié sa puissance musculaire par un
facteur de 110 autrement l'exosquelette
que nous nous sommes créées à base de
train dans beauty third extrudeur de
très fines aux deux cimenteries
d'aciéries de bateaux d'avions de frigo
de pompes etc
john smit et bien cet énorme
exosquelette que nous avons créée à tout
instant il est 200 fois plus puissant
que les muscles de l'humanité donc je
vous le redis encore autrement avec les
convertisseurs keith a mangé du pétrole
du gaz et du charbon et accessoirement
le reste on a créé de toutes pièces une
exoplanète 2400 milliards de bons hommes
qui pédalent en permanence comme
charlton heston dans son line green là
et qui nous envoie l'énergie
correspondante
parce qu'on l'a créé
sans avoir besoin de les nourrir
exactement les nourrissant au pétrole au
gaz et au charbon alors c'est vachement
bien juste c'est pas renouvelable mais
pour le moment c'est vachement bien et
le système qu'on a bâtie par dessus est
un système qui est dépendant de la
pérennité ou pas de ça ça et ça alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a bâtie par dessus la
retraite à 52 ans pour les cheminots les
dix semaines de congés payés pour les
gens chez edf les week-ends et les cinq
semaines de congés payés pour les gens
comme moi le fait que j'ai terminé mes
études à 25 ans parce qu'à l'époque où
il y avait pas l'énergie abondant des 15
ans ou dès 12 ans j'aurais été dans les
champs en train de ramasser des patates
comme tout le monde le fait qu' on peut
partir
loin comme ça le fait qu'on ait pu
concentrer dans les villes des gens qui
n'ont pas de fonction productive sur la
matière voilà tout ça c'est des
contreparties de l'énergie abondante
tout ça alors que cette énergie elle est
un pouvoir l'énergie fossile soit
beaucoup plus efficace que les énergies
renouvelables je vais vous en donner un
exemple ici un sol un
plein d'autres je vais prendre une
énergie dans le vent sans mauvais jeu de
mots donc l'énergie éolienne
imaginons que vous preniez un cube de
kiko enfin deux mille mètres cube d'air
pendant qu'un cube de 10 mètres de côté
l'a7 saleh doit faire à peu près 10
mètres sur 10 mètres et elle fait deux
mètres cinquante de haut donc vous
prenez quatre fois le volume d'air de
cette salle et vous imaginez que se
taire souffle à 80 km/heure
c'est à dire 45 pour ceux qui font de
l'avion c'est pas bien ça concept du
pétrole ou du bateau à voile de ces
lieux et vous l'injecter dans une
éolienne et bien l'énergie que vous
allez récupérer en sortie est la même
que celle que vous avez dans 3000 litres
de pétrole ce qui ne fait pas beaucoup
et par ailleurs avec cette énergie là
vous la mettez vous l'avez à la
disposition et vous vous en servez quand
vous voulez donc si vous avez décidé
qu'avec cette énergie là votre voiture
partait à 8 heures du matin elle part à
8 heures du matin avec cette énergie là
tant que vous n'avez pas stocker votre
voiture par quand il ya du vent
donc quand y'a pas devant vous appelez
en fait vous l'appelez pas parce qu a
pas d'électricité pas de vent donc vous
envoyer un pigeon voyageur à votre
patron en disant je viens pas au boulot
parce qu a pas de banc si votre patron
en tant que vous alliez au boulot à 8
heures du matin même quand ya pas de
vent il va falloir prendre cette énergie
et la stocker à ce moment effectivement
vous avez pas besoin de laurier un
pigeon voyageur vous pouvez vraiment
aller au bureau à 8 heures quand ya pas
de vent c'est une autre manière de dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de faire
une comparaison méthodologique invalides
en permanence qui est de comparer le
coût au mégawattheure des énergies
fatales avec le cou aux qui au médiateur
des énergies pilotable si vous remplacez
du nucléaire à 100 euros du
mégawattheures pilotable par de l'éolien
à 80 euros du mégawattheures non
pilotable dans le deuxième cas de figure
vous n'allez pas au bureau quand ya pas
de vendre
donc ce que vous avez économisé à la
production il ya une toute petite
contrepartie de l'autre côté
donc évidemment tout le monde se garde
bien de parler quand on fait ce genre de
comparaison en fait la seule comparaison
légitime
les agents revient aussi à un truc qui
drive pourtant des politiques publiques
de manière très puissante
la seule comparaison légitime quand vous
avez un vote fatale et à votre pilotable
il y en a que deux soit vous comparer le
coût complet du mode fatale avec son
stockage
donc je vous dit je veux conserver le
pacte social qu'on a aujourd'hui dans la
société qui est que l'énergie est
disponible quand les gens le souhaitent
d'accord donc l'ademe a organisé un
colloque ici qui démarrait à ses heures
est donc assez hors l'ademe souhaite que
y'a d'électricité qui permettent
d'alimenter vidéoprojecteur elle dit pas
je fais un colloque virgule ci a du bon
alors qui démarre à 16 heures et donc à
ce moment il faut rajouter le moyen de
rendre le mode fatale pilotable donc ça
doit être inclus dans le coût ou bien
vous dites je j'ai le mode fatale et je
garde de votre pilotable par ailleurs
pour faire le backup et à ce moment là
bonne comparaison c'est le combustible
et éviter dans le vote dans le mode
pilotable versus le coût complet du vote
fatale et donc à ce moment les 80 euros
du mégawattheures de l'éolien où les 60
vous devez les comparer aux 10 euros du
mégawattheures hors coût du co2 de la
limite pour 20 euros du mégawattheure au
coût du co2 du charbon ou au 40 euros du
mégawattheures hors coût du co2 du gaz
ou eau en première approximation zéro
parce que la durée de vie du combustible
dans le réacteur dépend pas tellement de
combien on va tirer dessus parce que les
arrêts de tranche sont programmées avec
des contraintes qui décide enfin voilà
qui sont marginalement ajusté avec ce
genre de truc donc en première
approximation 0 du nucléaire a les bété
mettez 2 euros du mégawattheures si vous
voulez donc en france tant que l'éolien
et le solaire ce coûte plus cher que 2
euros du mégawattheures c'est pas
concurrentiel avec le nucléaire
installée
c'est ça la bonne base de comparaison
c'est évidemment pas là une histoire
qu'on vous sert tous les joueurs donc là
si je fais une comparaison de coûts donc
ici j'ai en mode fatale six à huit
centimes par kilowattheure mais si je
rajoute le stockage ont multiplié par
trois au bas mot voire plus et de
l'autre côté mon kilowattheures
d'énergie déjà stocké beaucoup de 0,3
centime
c'est le reflet du fait que l'argent ne
paye que les hommes l'argent ne paye pas
la nature et ça demande beaucoup moins
de travail humain d'extraire de
l'énergie de l'environnement de cette
manière que de l'extraire de cette
manière c'est pour ça qu historiquement
on est passé des moulins à vent au match
au moteur à combustion interne
les grands moulins de paris ils sont
passés de la voilà c'est ça qu'ils ont
fait historiquement et la raison vous
l'avez là c'est physique alors on peut
chercher à invalider la physique par un
vote à l'assemblée nationale je prends
les paris avec qui veut sur la somme
d'argent que vous voulez sur le succès
de la faire donc je prends je m'installe
à la sortie là le devant de terre on
prends tous les paris avec qui veut
évidemment que ça marchera pas ça
n'empêche pas le poids la puissance
publique de se comporter comme tels en
tablant notamment sur l'ignorance d'un
certain nombre de gens et sur
l'incapacité de la presse a joué
correctement son rôle quand il s'agit de
diffuser les faits mais elle n'est pas
faite pour ça en fait quand on regarde
bien dont vous avez un delta de prix
entre les deux qui est de quelques
dizaines voire plus et en plus je vous
rappelle que si l'énergie ici et
renouvelables dispositif de collecte ne
l'est pas parce que l'éolienne
aujourd'hui est fait à base d'énergies
fossiles et de minerais non
renouvelables donc l'énergie
renouvelable dispositif de collecte non
non quand donc quand on dit ça c'est une
énergie verte
ouais enfin je le redis on aurait pu
l'appeler énergie bleu blanc rouge rose
gris à paillettes
donc quoi c'est de l'énergie éolienne
collectées par une éolienne
voilà et il faut regarder le truc dans
le détail pour savoir si oui ou non on
va pouvoir vivre là dessus pendant deux
siècles avec 30000 euros de pib par
france a fait à 30000 euros de revenus
par français et par an voilà alors dans
les autres malentendu qu'on a dans
d'autres pays vous avez évidemment tous
entendu que la france était un pays tout
nucléaire et ça c'est une autre capacité
qu'on a dans d'autres pays c'est celle
de réduire le débat à une de ses
composantes
c'était déjà le cas en 2003 c'était le
cas en 2012 ça sera le cas dans trois
ans je vois pas pourquoi
ça changerait pourrait entrer dans le
détail pour expliquer pourquoi vous avez
ici la quantité d'énergie utilisée par
secteur en france alors ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire c'est l'énergie
utilisée c'est gratuit c'est pardon
c'est des milliards de kilowattheures
des térawattheures et la barre dépend de
l'endroit où va ce que se trouve la
machine qui utilise l'énergie
donc si la machine aller chez vous là où
vous habitez et qu'elle sert à vous
chauffez ça s'appelle résidentiel et ça
s'appelle chauffage aller à prendre des
douches aussi si elle sert à autre chose
cuisson ascenseur éclairage frigo
whatever la même chose dans les
bâtiments qui servent à une activité
économique chauffage autre chose sauf
les procédés industriels donc si les
machines servent à fabriquer des objets
c'est là si les machines sont dans les
champs c'est là et si les machines
servent à déplacer des personnes ou des
marchandises c'est là d'accord et chaque
couleur représente l'énergie primaire
qui a servi à alimenter les machines
après transformation maintenant je sers
que tout ce qui vient des hydrocarbures
dans notre pays et je vous pose la
question pensez vous que la france soit
un pays tout nucléaire pour presser à un
élève de primaire
vous enlevez nucléaire pétrole machin
vous mettez un sucre farine of l'est et
vous lui dites est ce que tu crois que
cela grézian du gâteau c'est ça vient
vous dire non non ce n'est pas le seul
gagnant du gâteau bon ça n'empêche pas
la presse de continuer à ânonner ce
slogan stupide que la france est un pays
tout nucléaire donc moyennant quoi on
s'occupe pas de ça qui est déjà en
décrue subi en europe et qui est déjà à
l'origine de nos déboires économiques
monsieur ristori ci devant directeur
général de la direction générale de
l'énergie à la commission européenne ne
s'est pas que l'europe enfin il ya deux
ans il ne savait pas que l'europe était
en décrue subi pétrolière ça y est je
pense que monsieur le maire le sait pas
plus je pense que vu log malheureusement
s'en fiche
donc c'est un tout petit sujet alors
dernier sujet de malentendu ça c'est un
graphique qui date d'il ya deux jours
enfin je les récupérer il ya deux jours
je connaissais déjà l'info et l'info en
fait la première fois que je les ai
entendus c'est grâce à une étude que
daniel bois fait depuis 2000
2 qui connais daniel bois dans cette
salle n'aime pas les gens de la donne
daniel bois il fait depuis 2002 une
enquête sur la perception du changement
climatique par les français et dans les
questions qu'il pose
il ya celle là alors maintenant l'ifop
la pose aussi pour chacun des éléments
suivants indiquer si selon vous il
contribue à l'effet de serre etc
alors vous avez l'industrie
l'agriculture les transports machin etc
il y en a un c'est les centrales
nucléaires regardez la réponse des
français ça c'est beaucoup et ça c'est
un peu ça c'était en 2014
ça c'est en 2015 c'est en 2016 et ça
c'est en 2017
donc vous avez 77% des français qui
pensent qu'en baissant le nucléaire dans
l'électricité on contribue à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
77% des français donc le gouvernement
qui se garde bien de rectifier ce fait
ça les arrange
c'est quand même sympa de marier une
promesse électorale avec le fait que
vous avez accordé la physique à ce que
vous êtes en train de faire un surf sur
un monstrueux malentendu parce que vous
pouvez reprocher tout ce que vous voulez
le nucléaire mais jusqu'à preuve du
contraire fissionner un noyau d'uranium
en deux ça n'est pas oxydée un atome de
carbone
je peux répéter doucement un fissionner
à noyaux d'uranium
c'est pas oxydée un atome de carbone
d'accord donc yaya
voilà donc une illustration de plus des
malentendus voilà ça c'était juste une
petite illustration que j'aime bien
2 une toute petite partie de nos
esclaves des temps modernes tout à fait
mort au 1
tout à fait admis non seulement ils sont
admis mais on cherche à les augmenter
partout et tout le temps parce que
l'aide au développement par exemple
c'est d'augmenter ce genre de trucs puis
après on dit ah merde les pays émergents
font plus de missions c'est d'augmenter
sa ces convertisseurs qui ont leur
nourriture particulière et qui ont une
fort qui nous amène une force mécanique
qui du coup vont permettre de remplacer
les hommes alors cette affaire là et
c'est là que j'en viens à l'île de
france ça fortement structurée l'emploi
vous avez ici une évolution qui concerne
au premier chef l'île de france parce
que il n'y aurait pas 10 millions de
franciliens
s'il n'y avait pas eu de gaz pétrole et
charbon et il n'y aurait pas d emploi de
bureau pour quasiment 10 millions de
franciliens
s'il n'y avait pas eu gaz pétrole et
charbon d'accord donc vous toutes là ce
qui est dans cette salle ça m'étonnerait
que vous soyez agriculteurs si vous avez
le boulot et ça m'étonnerait que vous
soyez ouvriers si vous avez le boulot
que vous avez c'est à cause du pétrole
du gaz et du charbon alors j'explique un
tout petit peu vous avez ici la cr en
séries longues l'emploi en france sur
deux siècles
j'en profite pour faire une petit 1,6
quand vous voulez comprendre un
processus
essayez de disposer des séries les plus
longue possible essayez de disposer des
séries les plus longue possible la
quantité de contresens qu'on peut faire
quand on prend une série courte est
absolument phénoménal alors en économie
on adore faire ça alors prendre des
séries très courte et puis du coup
comprendre le prime de travers il faut
vraiment garder les trucs sur les séries
les plus haut possible
c'est pas facile évidemment donc ici
vous avez la structure de l'emploi ce
que vous constatez il ya deux siècles
c'est que les gens qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture
c'est plus de la moitié de la les deux
tiers par dons de la population active
ce qui signifie deux choses la première
c'est que la productivité d'un
agriculteur est suffisante pour qu'il se
nourrisse lui plus d'une demi personne
qui fait autre chose
et la deuxième chose que ça signifie
c'est que vous n'avez pas beaucoup
d'urbain parce que les agriculteurs sont
rarement en ville
vous avez la population agricole qui va
augmenter un peu entre 1800 et 1850
alors à cette époque-là l'industrie
s'étant pas vraiment de la proto
industrie ça n'aide pas beaucoup ça ne
change pas beaucoup et la productivité
par personne ce qui va se passer à ce
moment là c'est que en coupant des
forêts on est capable d'augmenter les
surfaces cultivées à ce moment on peut
nourrir plus de monde donc la population
est capable d'augmenter et à proportion
la quantité d'agriculteurs à partir des
10150 vous commencez à avoir des sorts
industriel qui va mettre à la
disposition des agriculteurs en quantité
croissante des outils plus performants
pour cultiver collier de trek est
capable d'être fabriquée en plus grande
quantité d charolles plus performante
des bad etc
fabre bref donc la proto industrie
commencent à fournir à l'agriculture des
outils qui permettent d'augmenter la
productivité agricole et dans le même
temps l'énergie croissante donc a permis
de faire les forges et l'industrie qui
augmente la productivité des
agriculteurs
à ce moment un agriculteur peut nourrir
plus de personnes donc vous enlevez une
condition aux limites pour mettre plus
de personnes ailleurs et vous avez
également de l'énergie qui permet
d'extraire de l'environnement autre
chose que de la photosynthèse que
l'agriculture extrait de la
photosynthèse de l'environnement donc
vous pouvez extraire des pierres de
carrière des métaux etc et donner du
travail à tous les gens dont le métier
est d'extraire des matières minérales il
transforme et ça s'appelle l'industrie
et à la suite de l'industrie quand vous
augmenter la production industrielle
vous augmentez de choses vous augmentez
les comptables vous augmentez les
restaurants et vous augmentez les gens
de maison chez les gens qui ont fait
fortune dans l'industrie dont vous avez
les services vous augmentez les
banquiers vous aurez etc
donc vous avez tout ça qui suit derrière
et puis après la guerre on va pas mieux
équiper les paysans on va les remplacer
parce que quand vous prenez un tracteur
un tracteur de quelques dizaines de
kilowatts développe la même puissance
mécanique que quelques centaines de
personnes ou quelques dizaines d'animaux
de trait donc vous mettez des tracteurs
dans les champs et vous être capable de
virer tous les gens qui étaient dans les
champs à la place des tracteurs et par
ailleurs la deuxième chose qui va
accroître encore sa et qui vient aussi
de l'énergie fossile ces développements
engrais le pétrole permet de transporter
à la surface de la planète phosphates et
potasse très facilement parce que vous
avez quelques gisements très productif
dans le monde
donc après il faut les quand même plus
facile que d'avoir ces éléments minéraux
qui viennent du fumier de cheval
ça va plus vite et la deuxième chose que
vous allez faire c'est faire des engrais
azotés et le début de la fabrication des
engrais azotés c'est l'extraction du gaz
les engrais azotés c'est un sous produit
de la fabrication de l'ammoniaque qui
elle-même est une chimie qui s'opèrent à
partir du gaz qui tout naturel qu'il
avait quand même une énergie fossile
pour ceux qui aiment bien les
dirigeables et qui pensent qu'on va
remplacer l'aviation par des dirigeables
à l'hélium je vous dis par ailleurs un
truc qui va peut-être vous amuser
l'hélium est également un sous-produit
d'utilisation de de l'extraction du gaz
donc quand on extraira plus de gaz
naturel énergie fossile y aura plus
d'hélium donc ça va être un peu con pour
faire des dirigeables à l'hélium enfin
bon point sur les faits relais d'orange
n est pas très grave
donc on met les machines dans les champs
et à ce moment là quantité
d'agriculteurs ces fonds
donc la quantité d'agriculteurs vous le
verrez dans pas longtemps et simplement
une fonction inverse de la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne dans
un pays très simplement
cette énergie croissante permet donc de
mettre des machines pas que dans
l'agriculture ailleurs et donc on en mai
dans l'industrie dont on extrait de plus
en plus de matériaux du coup on est
capable d'employer de plus en plus de
gens pour transformer tout ça parce
qu'en fait à cette époque là la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne
augmente la quantité d'énergie
augmentent plus vite que la déco la
démographie donc si la quantité
d'énergie par personne augmente ça veut
dire que vous avez de plus en plus de
machines par personne en moyenne et donc
vous pouvez augmenter l'emploi dans
l'industrie
parce que dans l'industrie un emploi
c'est une machine que fait un ouvrier
dans l'industrie il est au service d'une
machine
pas de machines pas d'emploi l'ouvrier
est au service de la machine dans les
travaux publics aujourd'hui c'est pareil
conducteur de camion est au service du
camion le l'opérateur de marteau piqueur
est au service du marteau piqueur et le
type qui enlève les bandes blanches avec
son
son chalumeau à gaz là est au service du
chalumeau à gaz
si j'enlève le camion le marteau piqueur
et celle du bois gaz et que je donne à
ces gens là juste leurs mains nues voir
juste des pelles et des pioches travaux
publics vont pas vraiment avant la vente
est donc l'augmentation de l'énergie et
l'augmentation des machines permet
d'augmenter l'activité dans ce secteur
et puis après les chocs pétroliers
l'énergie par personnes s'arrêtent
d'augmenter dans les pays occidentaux en
fait ce qui va se passer au moment des
chocs pétroliers c'est que l'énergie par
personnes s'arrêtent d'augmenter et si
l'énergie par personnes s'arrêtent
d'augmenter mais que la taille moyenne
de la machine manipulé dans l'industrie
continue d'augmenter
à ce moment vous avez le nombre
d'emplois dans l'industrie qui baisse
c'est très exactement ce qui s'est passé
la production industrielle elle continue
d'augmenter en france entre les chocs
pétroliers et 2007
vous pouvez oublier la dz la
désindustrialisation la production
industrielle a été multiplié par deux
donc la délocalisation qui fait qu'il ya
plus de production industrielle c'est
n'importe quoi
on a arrêté de faire des chaussettes et
on a fait des airbus mais la production
industrielle a augmenté elle se met à
baisser à partir de 2007 à cause du
stress énergétique
si on parle aujourd'hui il n'empêche que
la production industrielle augmentant la
quantité de services peut augmenter
parce que qu'est-ce que les services se
sont comme leurs noms l'indiquent des
services aux flux physiques ceux des
services aux flux physiques
prenons un exemple si demain matin les
ventes de voitures passent en france de
2 millions de voitures à une voiture
part en une c'est une contraction de
l'industrie automobile d'accord assez
vite derrière vous à les contracter
l'assurance automobile services vous à
les contracter le crédit auto service
vous allez contracté la réparation des
voitures service vous à les contracter
le commerce des drive services etc etc
vous avez contracté les cinémas où les
gens viennent en bagnole donc en fait
vous vous rendez compte que les services
ne sont pas capables de vivre leur vie
indépendamment de la production
industrielle prenons un autre exemple
l'enseignement
si vous arrêtez de construire des
bâtiments et que vous voulez ce qui
existe tombent en lambeaux et bien vous
arrêter d'avoir des enseignants parce
qu'enseigner dehors sous la flotte au
milieu de l'hiver quand même un peu
compliqué du reste les places en plein
air dans la cité rixe ont toujours lieu
l'été on se demande bien pourquoi donc
vous avez tous les services en fête
repose sur des flux industriels sous
jacent les services que vous seriez
capable d'assurer au milieu du vide
intersidéral sans production
industrielle ira pas d'accord donc ils
sont tous assis sur des flux industriels
sous jacents et l'idée qu'on va
dématérialiser la société en ayant que
des emplois de service
c'est comme l'élixir de jouvence de tout
à l'heure c'est à peu près aussi
vraisemblable sauf que il ya quand même
un petit truc qui se met à se passer au
moment des chocs pétroliers les services
continuent d'augmenter parce que la
production industrielle continue à
augmenter mais vous commencez à avoir
une première disponibilité dans le
système et vous voyez apparaître une
nouvelle catégorie d'emploi si je puis
dire qu'ils n'existaient pas avant que
j'appelle les chômeurs ça veut dire que
le monde
à ce moment là commence déjà à ne plus
être assez vaste il commence déjà à être
suffisamment fini pour que vous ne
pouvez vous ne puissiez pas offrir un
emploi à tout le monde dans un contexte
de croissance globale déjà à ce moment
là vous ne pouvez plus
alors voilà la traduction statique de ce
que je viens de vous dire sur
l'agriculture en dynamique donc là je
vous ai montré la france sur deux
siècles
là je vous montre le monde en 2013 le
monde en 2013 c'est ce nuage de points
rouges très joli et chaque point
représente un pays et pour chaque pays
j'ai mis en abscisse la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne dans
le pays en question et en ordonnée la
fraction de la population active qui
travaillent dans l'agriculture
vous voyez c'est extrêmement simple dis
moi combien d'énergie par personne tu
consommes et je te dirai quelle est la
quantité de paysans que tu as chez toi
alors de ça une première question pour
le territoire francilien
quand la quantité d'énergie par personne
va se mettre à faire ça comment est-ce
qu'on organise ça
comment est-ce que je dégonfle l'île de
france pour remettre des gens à faire
des yaourts et à faire pousser des
patates
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est absolument
pas ce qu'on leur promet on leur promet
des highlights tech machin des lunettes
google en 3d jeux pourquoi on fait des
conneries pour gamins ces conneries
qu'on regarde mais là on a un petit
sujet là et en plus ça pourra pas être
en ile-de-france aujourd'hui
d'ile-de-france produit 6% de sa
nourriture
donc là je suis en train de vous dire
une chose je suis en train de vous dire
que la construction des villes est un
sous produit de l'énergie abondante
permettant de ne plus avoir la
population à la campagne et que
l'aménagement du territoire qui fait
sens dans un monde où l'énergie se
contracte s'est dégonflé les villes
brouage et si vous le faites pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe que
la résilience économique de la ville
commence à être attaquée et elle
commencera à être attaqué
là où l'énergie est la plus
indispensable pour que les flux continue
à s'organiser c'est à dire les banlieues
donc la manière dont vous pouvez voir
qu'un pays commencent à être sous stress
d'approvisionnement énergétique sait
quand ça commence à aller mal dans les
banlieues de ces villes et c'est très
exactement là que se trouvent les
populistes qui trouve pas l'histoire
rôle
enfin personne de trouve histoire drôle
mais je veux dire les électeurs des
populistes repas l'histoire drôle donc
ils votent avec leurs pieds
alors tant que l'énergie augmentent
voilà ce que ça donne vous avez ici
l'aménagement urbain en france
avant guerre l'aménagement urbain appris
hier
il ya quelques années vous voyez les
villes ont grossi grâce à l'énergie
abondante qui permet d'avoir un
hinterland extrêmement vaste et de faire
venir tout ce qu'on mange et tout ce
qu'on porte sur soi et tout ce qu'on
achète de plus en plus loin et c'est
nécessaire encore une fois ci le bassin
d'approvisionnement de l'île de france
aujourd'hui c'était 200 km on serait un
foutu de donner à manger aux franciliens
on serait un foutu de les vêtir et on
serait évidemment un foutu de vous
fournir vos ordinateurs
on serait un foutu de nous fournir notre
mobilier enfin on fournit plus rien quoi
donc plus une ville est grosse plus ses
racines s'étendent loin donc elles sont
grosses et par ailleurs vous voyez que
les campagnes se sont vidés et la
question de savoir si la ville et danser
et à laisser un déterminant du deuxième
ordre donc pendant très longtemps j'ai
pensé que ce qui était important c'était
que la ville dans son fonctionnement du
quotidien sur la mobilité et le
chauffage ne consomme pas beaucoup
d'énergie en fait j'ai fini mais à mon
âge on est un peu lent j'ai fini par
arriver à la conclusion qu'en fait le
truc important ce n'est pas tellement
qu'elle soit dans souhaité aller c'est
qu'elle soit grosses ou petites
donc le premier facteur de vulnérabilité
d'une ville dans un monde à l'énergie
contrainte c'est sa taille elle est très
performant tant que l'énergie est
abondant entre cantal et très grosse
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui elle
concourt de quéquette entre tous les
maires du monde entier pour avoir une
plus grosse que celle du voisin
donc les plus grosses villes par contre
parce que on est player mondiale etc
je considère pour ma part que le grand
paris est un anachronisme
c'est à dire que c'était vachement bien
de le faire il ya un siècle et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est juste une énorme
connerie
aujourd'hui c'est une énorme connerie
urbanisées les terres du plateau de
saclay qui sont parmi les meilleures
terres à blé de france je le sais pas
parce que je ne sais pas parce que je
suis un militant parce que j'ai demandé
un agriculteur qui les cultivent et qui
n'est pas du tout un écolo wife et du
conventionnel stadler l'a dit mais les
jeudis il paraît qu'il va dire oui c'est
parfaitement clair donc urbanisées ses
terres à blé tout ça pour mettre
ensemble des chercheurs qui aurait très
bien pu travailler ensemble s'il était
resté là où il était c'est juste un truc
totalement anachronique totalement
anachronique
donc là voilà un exemple où la dynamique
des systèmes vous dit
voilà ce que l'énergie a fait donc
réfléchissez as que ses paires heinz et
thomas rien [ __ ] enfin il faut dire
que christian blanc qui a fait partie
des promoteurs du truc est quand même un
mec un peu space
oui il a écrit un livre qui s'appelle la
croissance ou le chaos dans lequel il
écrit que la production d'un champ est
strictement proportionnelles au nombre
de paysans qui y travaillent vous prenez
un hectare vont multiplier les paysans
qui travaillent dans parmi les la
production augmente par mille
harry potter et enfoncez vous avez ici
les déplacements du quotidien en
ile-de-france alors ça c'est un autre
effet liés à l'énergie abondante en 1975
donc c'est la distance domicile travail
donc vous voyez partout où ces blancs
c'est moins de 5 km et c'est donc ici ça
veut dire que c'est agricole ça que ça
veut dire là aussi je suis là aussi là
c'est très dense donc les gens vont à
pied ils ont au bureau voilà où en métro
et vous voyez quand même que globalement
il n'y a pas énormément d'endroits où
les gens ont besoin de beaucoup se
déplacer pour aller travailler
et puis ça c'est la même chose en 1999
alors soit dit en passant le grand paris
il va être là le problème
il a donc on va [ __ ] 40 milliards dans
la résolution d'un problème qui n'existe
pas avec les honneurs on met 100
milliards dans la résolution d'un
problème qui n'existe pas donc ya pas de
problème pour mettre des milliards dans
des projets qui existent pas 100
milliards à ce jour les nerfs vous
faites sigma des contrats signés sur le
solaire et l'éolien à fin 2016 100
milliards les gens gueulent parce qu'on
a arrêté sur les apl 5 euros par mois je
sais pas quoi vous faites le total des
sommes qui sont concernés vous êtes un
deux ordres de grandeur en dessous un
donc là sans que personne ne bronche 100
milliards et là quelques dizaines qui
vont pas servir à grand chose
alors pourquoi ce qu'on fait tous ces
trucs là une des raisons c'est à cause
de cet individu et ses petits copains ya
deux siècles parce que à cette époque là
au moment où naît l'économie classique
et aujourd'hui l'indicateur qui est
l'alpha et l'oméga de tous les
indicateurs que nous manipulons c'est à
dire les euros
l'ademe manipule quelques euros
budget lorsque les oraux sont plus
importants à l'ademe qu un kilowattheure
lui reste comme partout ailleurs
et bien notre ami jean baptiste say puis
on vire personnes à l'ademe au nom des
kilowattheures alors qu'on a des europe
le faire monsieur jean baptiste say
qu'est ce qui dit il dit les
kilowattheures on s'en fout ce n'est pas
un sujet on s'en fout et en fait tous
les économistes classiques à l'époque
ils disent l'économie va compter ce qui
est rare
la nature n'est pas rare est infinie
donc elles vont 0 donc on l'a compte pas
on s'en fout c'est ça qui fait à cette
époque là et on avance donc un système
qui est le système économique dans
lequel ça c'est gratuit donc la nature
s'est crevé pendant 14 milliards
d'années c'est quand même un peu plus
long qu'une révision du bac 1 14
milliard d'années pour faire un système
terre les 92 éléments du tableau de
mendeleïev assemblée dans toutes les
combinaisons possibles 30 millions
d'espèces vivantes un océan
enfin plus exactement des océans un
système climatique des montagnes des
écosystèmes des sols cultivables des
minerais un peu partout kratos ne nous a
pas coûté un centime
tout ça est gratuit alors essayé de
refaire le pib mondial au milieu du vide
intersidéral c'est à dire sans ça allait
quand même avoir quelques problèmes
donc c'est essentiel et c'est gratuit
c'est ça notre problème c'est que c'est
essentiel et c'est gratuit donc monsieur
sait il a forgé une vision qui est
aujourd'hui la vision communément admise
à la fois dans le monde politique et
chez les économistes
académique qui ont leurs oreilles qui
est un système sans limite
vous avez deux facteurs de production la
population et le capital est à ce moment
le supermarché est plein personne ne
vous dit avec cette vision la vision
économique classique quand le pib
mondiale atteindra 126 milles 382
milliards de dollars il s'arrête alors
que tout à l'heure je voulais montrer
que le diamètre de la terre quand vous
aller d'un bout à l'autre quand vous
avez atteint un peu plus de 13 mille
kilomètres ça s'arrête
vous sortez vous allez vous montez dans
l'atmosphère quand vous avez fait entre
7 et 15 km selon la latitude vous
arrêté dans la troposphère s'arrête si
vous montez une main le long de mon
corps va arriver au dessus de la tête 72
ça s'arrête donc tous les systèmes
physiques ont une fin et là on a inventé
une représentation conventionnelle du
monde qui nous entoure parce que
l'économie est une représentation
conventionnelle qui n'a pas de limites
c'est quand même merveilleux merveilleux
donc l'infini est à notre portée et
l'infini est à notre portée parce que à
l'époque je leur dis où on a fait la
composent la programmation au premier
ordre avec la monnaie enfin avec les
avec les euros avec la production avec
l'économie eh bien on a dit les deux
seuls trucs qui compte c'est le capital
et le travail
alors ça explique pourquoi quand ça ça
commence à patauger et que les cheminots
gueule les retraités gueule les
étudiants gueule et c'est que la dame
gueule pour son buteur n'y a pas de
problème pour augmenter sa je vais
augmenter ça dont on fait du
quantitative easing partout on a que la
mode est aujourd'hui c'est simple vous
vous appuyez sur un bouton sur la touche
critères sur le clavier de retour de
votre ordinateur et vous avez créé 50
milliards d'euros
aussi simple que ça crée de la monnaie
aujourd'hui donc on en crée plein et
puis on botte le cul des feignants en
leur disant tu vas pas bosser pour
l'emploi va passer chez toi à vérifier
va tirer etc bref condé taxent le
travail en détaxe le coût horaire
terrain propres ailes et puis comme dit
l'autre ça mieux pas quand vous regardez
la production industrielle en 2017
en europe elle est inférieure à ce
qu'elle était en 2007 inférieure
le trafic routier sur les autoroutes
pour les marchandises est inférieur
l'index de la construction est inférieur
la production industrielle est inférieur
donc ça que ça doit pas être ça la
représentation du système parce que
sinon ça marcherait alors en fait la
présentation du système est assez simple
certes vous avez besoin de gens pour
transformer et de capital mais en fait
vous avez besoin de retrouver ici les
atomes que
enfin tous les atomes du tableau de
mendeleïev que vous avez là dedans vous
avez besoin de les prendre quelque part
donc vous avez besoin des ressources en
entrée vous faites pas un fauteuil sans
du pétrole qui va vous fournir les
fibres synthétiques cent du minerai de
fer qui va vous faire l'armature en
métal d'accord vous n'êtes pas assis sur
du vide là en ce moment comme bip bip et
le coyote la non vous êtes assis vous
êtes assis sur des fauteuils biens
matériels
donc cette matière on l'a prise quelque
part on l'a prise dans l'environnement
ça s'appelle des ressources et par
ailleurs on a transformé parce que vous
n'avez pas le cul sur du minerai de fer
dans ce moment donc on a transformé le
fauteuil et la transformation comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est
l'énergie et cette transformation on a
utilisé des convertisseurs qu'ils sont
nous mêmes et les machines et comme je
voulais dit tout à l'heure le ratio
entre les machines et nous c'est de là à
200 donc en fait le premier facteur
limitant sur la transformation mais là
il n'est pas là bas les hommes
aujourd'hui son surnuméraires c'est bien
la preuve qu' il ya des choses enfin la
preuve en est qu'elle est chômeur
partout donc vous pouvez lire et 10% de
la population mondiale et vous ne
changerez pas le pib d'un iota y en a
trop de toute façon on est en excès de
bonhomme pose aucun problème
l'allemagne a augmenté son pib en
décroissant sa population c'est bien la
preuve que sa note ça ne compte pas ça
ne compte pas ce qui compte c'est le
nombre de machines
il ya un siècle ou même il ya 60 ans le
pib français était supérieure au pib
chinois alors qu'à l'époque je vous
assure que la population chinoise était
supérieure à la population française
pourquoi parce que ce qui compte c'est
les machines donc à l'époque la france
avait plus de machines que la chine dont
le pib était supérieur points points
les etats unis ont eu le premier pib
mondial parce que en 1939 il produisait
70 % du pétrole mondial à lui tout seul
donc ils avaient plus de machines que
tout le monde donc il avait la première
puissance industrielle à l'époque où
c'était que les bras qui comptait il ya
bilan la chine avait premier pib mondial
de loin et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui elle est dans sa quête à la
croissance elle ne veut que retrouver
laurent multimillénaire qui a été le
sien
c'est juste ça je suis allé ensuite on
discutera lui sont bien partis pour si
vous avez un goulet d'étranglement sur
l'énergie pardon capitale c'est une
boucle interne si vous avez un goulet
d'étranglement sur l'énergie et bien
vous aurez un goulet d'étranglement sur
le nombre de machines au travail et donc
sur la production en sortie
même si vous avez des banquiers très
compatissant et même si vous avez plein
de gens qui sont prêts à bosser ça
compte pas si vous avez un goulet
d'étranglement sur les ressources par
exemple émis des ressources minérales
pour faire le grand paris et ben vous
aurez un peu moins de grand paris
d'accord il n'y a pas que le travail et
le capital comme facteur limitant dans
le système économique
or les autres indicateurs personne ne
les surveille donc vous pouvez faire de
la politique publique fo plaisamment
vous pouvez faire une analyse systémique
basée sur des indicateurs qui ne sont
pas dans les prix tout le monde s'en
fout les parias monsieur draghi des
ressources métallique monsieur leur a
dit s'en contrefout d'aller parler à
emmanuel macron il s'en contrefout aussi
leur est bien chez rothschild il a
quelques excuses donc il s'en contrefout
il comprend même pas de quoi il doit y
retourne je pense
s'il voit pas le sujet il se trouve que
malgré les horreurs que je suis en train
de vous raconter je suis depuis deux ans
chargé de cours à l'ena
sur l'impression d'avoir à faire un
martien a bon dos et oui alors voilà la
traduction de ce que je viens de vous
raconter
vous avez ici une courbe qui vous donne
depuis 1965 la valeur ajoutée totale
dans le monde c'est-à-dire le pib en
dollars constants est ici la quantité
totale d'énergie utilisée par les hommes
c'est à dire la quantité totale pardon
de machines utilisées par les hommes
en fait c'est ça que ça vous donne et
vous et vous avez une superbe droite
donc dis moi combien d'énergie tu
consommes en fait ça veut dire dis moi
combien de machines tu utilises et donc
je te dirai quel est ta production tant
qu a pas de facteur limitant sur les
ressources ou sur autre chose
voilà c'est aussi bête que ça et comme
l'énergie et fossiles voilà pourquoi
comme le dit l'excellent brice lalonde
ça fait 23 coop qu'on n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord parce que se mettre
d'accord sur une baisse rapide des
émissions de co2 de bienassis c'est se
mettre d'accord sur la manière
d'organiser une récession mondiale
fermez le ban ça n'arrivera jamais donc
on peut continuer à aller dans les kops
est très sympa mais moi j'ai été apposée
en 2008 j'ai été à copenhague en 2009
c'était absolument génial c'était
électrique comme ambiance j'adorais et
par ailleurs soit dit en passant 2009
est la seule coop où il s'est passé un
truc destructif la seule c'est pour ça
que les ong vexé ont qualifié cet échec
si j'ai quelques minutes devant moi pour
vous raconter ses anecdotes
pascal est intéressante donc on arrive à
copenhague alors copenhague c'est comme
tout les coop une assemblée générale
donc
imaginons vous soyez une ag de
copropriétaires on voit qu'ils
commencent à se marrer vous avez compris
vous êtes une ag de copropriétaires et
puis chacun à tour de rôle dans une
enceinte où il n'ya qu'une personne pour
attribuer la parole mais pas de syndic
c'est une assemblée de copropriétaires
il n'y a pas de syndic
alors personne n'a préparé quoi que ce
soit soumis au vote en entrée en disant
moi je sais j'ai consulté faites moi
confiance etc
voilà ce que n'ont pas de syndicats il
ya juste à temps de parole qui attribuer
voilà donc vous levez la main vous levez
la main ou lever la main les droits de
paris et à partir de ça il faut arriver
à mettre tout le monde d'accord sur un
texte contraignant
donc il faut que vous arrivez à vous
mettre d'accord sur les travaux
qu'on va faire la clé de répartition des
charges parce que vous rentrez n'ya pas
de clé de répartition des charges y en a
pas vous êtes dans un système onusien un
pays une voix à ce stade il ya pas de
répartition des charges et vous devez
par acclamation consensuel vous mettre
d'accord sur le montant des travaux
la nature des travaux la répartition des
charges et le calendrier des travaux qui
pense que la probabilité de succès est
supérieur à 0
ça n'arrivera jamais alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé à copenhague il s'est passé
exactement ça c'est à dire que en
arrivant le au début de la coop
vous savez quand les gens font des
propositions et que les propositions
sont pas consensuels on met les
expressions entre crochets et donc en
entrée de la coop il ya un draft de
papier qui est en discussion et dans
lequel il est dit les nations unies a
attendu que j'ai pas quoi donc là les
gens sont d'accord
l'assemblée des nations unies propose de
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 entre
crochets de entre crochets 2,5 entre
crochets 3 entre crochets trois et demi
entre crochets 4 entre crochets quatre
et demi entre crochets puisque s'arrêter
là et puis on a comme ça des centaines
des milliers dans le texte
bon alors au bout d'une semaine les gens
se sont mis d'accord sur rien
arrivent des ministres ils sont toujours
mis d'accord sur rien et arrivent les
présidents parce qu'on avait dit
copenhague ça va être un truc important
donc vous avez tous les présidents de la
terre qui arrive et il n'y a rien à
signer parce que les gens sont toujours
pas mis d'accord alors un président il
avait pas ça et à ce moment ce qui se
passe c'est que quelques présidents dans
lequel il paraît que sarkozy a joué un
rôle discriminant m'a dit brice lalonde
et tant mieux si c'est vrai prennent par
la main leur copain en disant écoutez on
peut pas repartir la queue basse comme
ça donc on va faire quelque chose et
donc vous avez overnight un conseil
d'administration qui fait irruption dans
le système c'est à dire les pays
puissants qu'ils lisent
on se réunit à 20 les autres fermer leur
gueule et sion ce qu'on va leur proposer
ce qui est le mode de gouvernance avec
lequel vous avancez c'est le mode de
gouvernance avec lequel vous avancez
tous ceux d'entre vous qui travaillent
dans les entreprises le patron vous dit
vous allez faire ça et si vous le faites
pas ils vous vire je veux dire c'est
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on avance
si tous les matins dans une entreprise y
avait une assemblée générale pour
décider du produit qu'on va vendre le
lendemain bon courage
bon donc c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche donc vous avez un conseil
d'administration qui se met en place et
à ce moment le conseil d'administration
fait un job de conseil d'administration
c'est à dire qu'il sort une feuille
blanche et puis m haies en 12 boulette
paint ce sur quoi les gens sont d'accord
dans les grands principes et alors les
présidents sorte au bout de quelques
heures
un drame de papier dans lequel ils
disent nous sommes d'accord pour 2
degrés donc les deux degrés date de
copenhague ils datent pas du tout paris
en date de copenhague nous sommes
d'accord pour 100 milliards de fonds
vert nous sommes d'accord pour la clause
de dommages canton tous les trucs majeur
que vous avez dans l'accord de paris il
date de copenhague de copenhague sauf
que nos amis danois
ils ont un peu manqué d'ambition et ils
ont dû mentionner le centre de
conférence pour 15000 personnes alors
quinze mille personnes c'est la quantité
de gens vous avez la première semaine
vous avez cinq mille journalistes 5000
fonctionnaires membres des délégations
et 5000 observateurs c'est à dire les
ong de toute nature pas seulement
environnemental pour l'égalité des sexes
pour la libération des tribus
amazoniennes vous avez tous assez rigolo
c'est très marrant donc 5000
représentants des ong
et puis arrive les délégations
présidentielle alors sarkozy c'est
soixante dix mais s'il y avait un il est
ridicule à côté d'obama qui arrive avec
2 100 ou 150 g par exemple 5000
personnes aussi ah qu'est ce qu'on fait
eh bien on fait un ordre de priorité les
délégations présidentielle sont
évidemment prioritaire ensuite la presse
est évidemment prioritaire et pour les
ong on passe de 5000 à 90 places
alors vous imaginez la sérénité des
dirigeants de lg qui sont victimes entre
guillemets de ce genre de truc qui
hurlent au complot est juste pas de
complot il y avait treize mille
personnes à poznan les danois sont dit
bon on va faire quinze mille à 0 complot
derrière vous pouvez éventuellement
parler d'incompétence si vous voulez il
n'ya 0 complot donc les ong éjecté
chauffé à blanc et à 3 heures du matin
dans la nuit du jeudi au vendredi quand
les premiers draft commencent à fuiter
alors je le sais parce que j'étais à
côté de la nana de la fp du desk
environnement de la fp
ap la discute avec elle l'a donc très
très bien de cela arrive une nana du vvf
avec le truc en deux pages et 12
boulette payne qui pose sa sur le bureau
de la journaliste en lui disant regarde
moi ça il ya que deux pages c'est un
scandale c'est un échec et l'eau est
partout et comme à ce moment là les
hauts fonctionnaires pouvait rien dire
parce que les présidents étaient en
train de discuter donc quand le
président discute vous abusez pas avoir
un navire
donc il y avait dans l'enceinte face à
la presse pas les dénégations
présidentielle puisqu'il était occupé à
discuter pas les fonctionnaires
puisqu'ils sont priés de fermer leur
gueule donc qu'est ce qui restait des
ong
donc vous avez 90 olibrius ayant des
problèmes d'ego chauffé à blanc qui sont
pavaner devant les caméras en disant
c'est un échec
ces gens là ont fait perdre six ans au
monde six ans ils ont fait perdre au
monde six ans parce que c'était pas du
tout un échec
c'était un immense succès on venait
enfin de se mettre d'accord sur les
objectifs
enfin c'était comme si votre assemblée
de copropriétaires venait enfin de
décider que le montant des travaux à
l'unanimité et par consensus s'était 200
millions et pas 400 et pas 300 et pas
222 voilà ce qui venait de se passer est
qu'on allait d'abord s'occuper de la
plomberie et ensuite de la toiture
ce n'est pas du tout un échec donc c'est
juste pour vous dire à partir de cette
petite courbe je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec brice quand il dit brice
lalonde qu il a tout fait depuis 72 1
absolument tout si un jour vous avez
l'occasion d'aller l'écouter allez-y
c'est passionnant ce qu'ils racontent
eh bien on a tout fait pardon depuis 23
ans on n'y arrive pas parce que c'est
pas possible de se mettre d'accord sur
l'organisation d'une récession mondiale
et heureusement pour une fois à la que
les politiques ont pas compris ce qu'ils
signaient parce que s'il avait compris
que deux degrés c'était la récession
mondiale il n'a jamais signé mais donc
c'est ça qui s'est passé à copenhague
c'est il ya eu un conseil
d'administration qui s'est installé aux
vernets alors pour autant le problème
n'est pas derrière nous et le prime
n'est pas derrière nous parce que le co2
est en occident alors je vais revenir un
peu de science je suis désolé oui je
veux mais je finis dans dix minutes
e le gens voient un qui regarde sa
montre la voie le co2 est un oxyde pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont fait un peu de
chimie vous savez probablement que les
oxydes seller forme stable des molécules
sur terre l'oxydé de fer est présent
dans la croûte terrestre depuis 4
milliards d'années et demi donc c'est
stable oxydes de fer le faire et pas
stable et rouille l'oxydé de fer
c'est stable tous les oxydes donc sondé
forme stable
le co2 est un oxyde dioxyde de carbone
donc c'est stable et une fois que vous
le mettez dans l'atmosphère comme c'est
stable il faut pas le camp parce que ces
sables c'est tout con mais c'est comme
ça et en pratique
quant à l'or il faut pas le camp il faut
quand même le camp mais lentement il
fout le camp avec deux processus qui ne
sont pas les processus chimiques ya un
processus de dissolution dans le dans
l'océan est un processus physiques et
dont du reste la limite c'est que la con
centrale à pression partielle de co2
deviennent la même dans l'océan et de
l'atmosphère
quand vous en arriver là le puits
océanique s'arrête et en ce qui concerne
la photosynthèse c'est une fausse ya
faute au foot ont donc il faut de
l'énergie
donc c'est un procédé endothermique les
besoins d'énergie mais sinon il s'en va
donc comme il s'en va pas facilement
quand vous créez un surplus de co2 dans
l'atmosphère ce que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui on est passé de 280 à 400
parties par million en l'espace d'un
siècle et demi on a donc créé un surplus
de co2 dans l'atmosphère que
normativement joe cole à 100 au début de
mon histoire
j'arrête demain matin les émissions en
direct et bien au bout d'un siècle 40%
de ce surplus est encore là au bout d'un
millénaire 20% de ce surplus est encore
là et au bout de dix mille ans 10% de ce
surplus est encore là ce que je viens de
vous dire c'est qu'il n'existe pas de
notion de remise en est
du système en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique en ce qui concerne
les conséquences pour aussi longtemps
que vous vivrez vos enfants aujourd'hui
aussi demain sera pire qu'aujourd'hui
pour aussi longtemps que vous vivrez et
vos enfants aussi à cause du fait que le
co2 est un oxyde et comme je ne pense
pas non plus qu'on changera le fait que
le co2 est un oxyde par un vote à
l'assemblée nationale ou par une
politique publique quelle qu'elle soit
il va falloir vivre avec
voilà donc on est sur des pattes temps
qui dépassent l'entendement et qui
dépasse surtout un mandat électoral
je rappelle pour ceux d'entre vous qui
n'était pas au courant
ce dont on parle quand on parle d'une
élévation de température un peu
significative vous avez ici les
écosystèmes installés en europe enfin
une représentation des éco systèmes
installés en europe
si vous ne le supprime et pas pour faire
les bureaux régionaux de l'ademe plus
tout un tas d'autres trucs qui sont
moins indispensable des chants des
routes des ponts des écoles là où vous
habitez etc
vous voyez qu'on a essentiellement à
faire à des forêts donc l'écosystème
climax x celui qui s'installe si on lui
fout la paix aujourd'hui c'est des
forêts donc des grosses espèces
végétales
ça veut dire qu'il pleut suffisamment et
que la température est sympa vous avez
quelques endroits où c'est pas le cas
donc là il pleut pas assez puis là il
fait trop froid et donc trop sec et vous
avez également un problème voilà
l'europe ya vingt mille ans donc à vingt
mille ans nous sommes au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire il fait plus
froid qu'aujourd'hui bien évidemment et
le paysage européen est extrêmement
différent de ce que nous pouvons voir
aujourd'hui
d'abord l'agencé européenne de
l'environnement qui est au danemark 3 1
copenhague c'est ça danemark et ben là
il nous emmerde plus les danois sont
sous la glace voilà les suédois nous
font pas la morale sur sous la glace
aussi donc c'est parfait
les finlandais de cause pas de problème
aux comptes d'areva ils sont sous la
glace
tout le monde est content vous avez une
énorme calotte de glace qui est posé sur
la scandinavie qui fait trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur et du reste elle a une
grande soeur se poser sur le canada qui
fait également trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur l'antarctique a également
grossi le groenland aussi et tout ces
carottes en grossissant ont pris
tellement d'eau dans l'océan dont le
fond est toujours au même endroit que le
niveau de l'océan a baissé de 120 mètres
donc transmanche a fait faillite en fait
y'a pas de transmanche le tunnel sous la
manche a fait faillite aussi a pas
besoin de le creuser on passe à pied sec
les écossais nous emmerde pas dans
tournoi des six nations ils sont sous la
glace et on peut aller mettre la pâtée
aux irlandais à pied sec
les vods a dit vous voyez également que
le temps étant beaucoup plus froid il
est beaucoup plus sec quand le temps est
plus froid vous avez moins d'évaporation
donc moins de précipitation donc c'est
beaucoup plus sec l'endroit le plus sec
au monde c'est l'antarctique et le
milieu de l'antarctique où vous avez un
ou deux centimètres de précipitations
par an
c'est encore pire que dans l'essentiel
du sahara et donc la végétation n'a rien
à voir et les gros animaux en bout de
chaîne trophique que nous sommes on est
capable d'en nourrir 100 milles 1
en france avec quelques baies récoltées
l'été et quelques animaux qui sont pas
d'accord pour mais quand on arrive quand
même à attraper qui servent de
complément alimentaire d'envoyer 100
mille bon homme c'est à dire la
population d'un arrondissement parisien
quand la terre est passé du paysage de
gauche au paysage de droite pour
l'europe
tout ce qu'elle a fait c'est de se
réchauffer de 5 degrés en moyenne
planétaire et elle a fait ça en cinq
mille ans et à l'époque la migration des
sociétés humaines ne posait pas de
problème certes la société humaine
c'était quelques centaines de personnes
le chef prenait sa plus belle ma su
distribuer les baffes déménager tout le
monde et si on en perdait la moitié au
passage ce n'était pas un sujet ça n'a
absolument pas empêché l'espèce de
survivre à preuve vous êtes dans cette
salle il n'y avait pas la cgt ni amnesty
international pour s'émouvoir tout ça
n'était juste pas un sujet
aujourd'hui il est bien évident que une
élévation de température de même ordre
de grandeur
arrivant sur une échelle de temps 100
fois plus courte
appliquée à des sociétés qui se sont
sédentarisés ya dix mille ans et qui ne
peuvent pas déménager en prenant sur
leur dos toutes les infrastructures
qu'elles ont construite si vous essayez
de déménager notre dame de paris sur
votre dos quand même un peu compliqué il
est absolument évident pour moi que ce
genre de transition à large échelle va
engendrer des déstabilisations social
économique et donc politique et donc
créer des conflits partout donc la
transition en ile de france
ça veut aussi dire des hordes d'immigrés
qui vont arriver d'afrique du nord
d'afrique tout court voire de france ça
veut aussi dire ça aussi dire ça je peux
vous assurer qu aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
un responsable politique qui voit le
problème comme ça alors meadows dont on
parlait tout à l'heure je vous en
parlais 15 secondes
il se trouve que déjà en 1972 il avait
réfléchi à tout ça
il a réfléchi à tout ça alors meadows en
fait c'est un héritier de foresters qui
est professeur de dynamique des systèmes
web haïti et qui durant les années 60
avec l'informatique rudimentaire de
l'époque parce que je vous rappelle que
le premier ordinateur c'est dans les
années 50 un gignac commence à essayer
d'imaginer une manière de
modéliser l'avenir de l'humanité alors
elle dit l'humanité c'est quoi c'est une
population
elle mange elle produit des choses des
services elle tape dans un stock de
départ constitué de ressources et elle a
un exutoire une fois qu'elle a
transformée avec des sous produits
indésirables de cette transformation qui
s'appelle la pollution d'accord c'est ça
le l'idée générale de meadows les médias
aussi fait un modèle dans lequel vous
avez des asservissements dans tous les
sens par exemple quand vous avez plus de
ressources vous pouvez investir une
partie de ses ressources dans
l'agriculture étant vous n'avez pas de
facteur limitant la production agricole
augmente
du coup vous pouvez augmenter la
population en retour était d'accord vous
donc vous avez un système a servi avec
des boucles de rétroaction et ceux
d'entre vous qui ont fait de
l'électronique dans le pendant leurs
études ont regardé en général de la
dynamique des systèmes l'électronique
c'est exactement ça c'est
l'apprentissage de la dynamique des
systèmes alors meadows dit voilà je me
déguise et puis ma dose ileri fille
quand même que la modélisation qui fait
représente à peu près l'évolution passée
du monde et c'est exactement ce qu'ils
constatent au moment où il sort son
rapport alors au moment où il sort son
rapport meadows il n'a absolument pas
dit le monde va s'effondrer demain matin
il n'a même pas dit le monde va
s'effondrer en 2000
vous voyez nous arrivons ici en 2017 et
en 2017 avec la modélisation de meadows
on a toujours une population qui croît
on a toujours une production agricole
qui croit on a toujours une production
industrielle qui croit on a entamé le
stock de ressources non renouvelables
pas encore de manière monstrueuse et on
a commencé à créer des perturbations
environnementales partout pas encore de
manière monstrueuse
c'est après qu'on commence à rigoler et
donc mélodies dit en gros les
exponentielle étant ce qu'elles sont
précédées exponentielle et en
particulier cette petite blague sur
combien de temps il faut pour occuper
toute la mare avec dédé du phare ça vous
aider des nues phares dont la surface
double tous les jours
et puis au bout de 29 jours la moitié de
la barre est occupé combien de temps il
faut pour occuper l'autre moitié il faut
un jour
donc la magie des exponentielle c'est
que ça raccourci le temps de plus en
plus donc c'est pas parce qu'on a été
tranquille pendant trente ans qu'on est
encore tranquille pendant trente ans on
peut avoir été tranquille pendant 30 ans
et être encore tranquille pour trois ans
2 1 ou 6 mois
est ce que di bello c'est vous pouvez
tripoter l'optimisme sur les hypothèses
initiales dans tous les sens que vous
voulez tant que l'humanité veut
absolument que ça ça augmente le système
s'effondre sur lui même avant la fin du
21e siècle
d'accord les mails aux fait des calculs
en disant est ce qu'il ya un niveau
auquel ce truc là se stabilise forever
d'accord je monte le truc et après je le
stabilise et le chatelier respecter
c'est à dire que mon système ne sort pas
d'un état d' équilibre parce que si ça
monte au dessus de cet état là vous êtes
dans ce que meadows appel aux gorges
shutenko l'aps c'est à dire qu'à un
moment vous avez franchi le seuil et le
système par ce franchissement de seuil
est amoindrie et ne peux plus remplir sa
fonction derrière quoi que vous fassiez
donc vous avez over schouten
stabilisation par exemple vous avez une
pointe dassier qui s'approche
dangereusement d'une bâche en plastique
dans lequel vous avez de l'eau si elle
s'approche et qu'elle rentre un tout
petit peu de dents etc etc
vous avez le temps mettre une rustine
tout va bien si elle s'approche qu'elle
se met à tourner dans tous les sens et
c'est là vous êtes en over foot avec
collapse derrière vous pouvez plus rien
faire le truc ce vide irrémédiablement
donc meadows c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir combien la perturbation
va empêcher le système de retrouver
quelque chose
un état d' équilibre pertinents il avait
dit oh bah si on pousse le truc jusqu'au
bout après ça à tout s'effondre on peut
plus rien faire
et pour finir pour aujourd'hui ça a tout
petit sujet avec l'indicateur euros dont
on s'occupait tout à l'heure alors parce
que en gros la manière dont on raisonne
aujourd'hui c'est j'ai une valeur
ajoutée globale qui est influent je vous
rappelle que le pib c'est la
contrepartie monétaire d'un flux de
transformation donc cette influence est
pas un stock c'est pas une richesse
c'est les charges
quand vous augmentez quand vous avez
claqué votre héritage au casino vous
augmentez votre pib personnel
d'augmenter votre train de vie
transitoirement vous diminuez vos actifs
et vous augmentez transitoirement 30
c'est très exactement ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui l'augmentation du pib
consiste à diminuer les actifs naturels
pour augmenter notre train de vie ça
marche le temps que vous avez des actifs
naturels a dilapidé bien présent marche
plus alors en attendant tant que le pib
augmente c'est génial parce que le pib
de l'année n vous permet d'avoir de
l'argent pour traiter allez on va dire
sigma d'un côté et un nouveau problème b
de l'autre si vous augmentez le pib
l'année d'après vous voyez vous pouvez
avoir encore plus d'argent pour traiter
le problème a encore plus d'argent pour
traiter le problème des pires ajouté de
quoi traiter un problème c'est donc dans
un monde en croissance les élus peuvent
vous dire je vais mieux m'occuper de
l'année prochaine des handicapés que je
les fais l'année dernière et en même
temps je m'occuperai mieux des vieux des
jeunes des chômeurs du budget de l'ademe
du chiffre d'affaires de carbone 4 et de
la fabrication des coussins je fais tout
à la fois puisque mes moyens augmentent
d'accord je suis capable d'augmenter
partout et tout le temps
le problème c'est qu'en d'une année sur
l'autre le pib diminue le simple fait de
garder la même chose pour un problème
donné vous empêche de garder la même
chose pour les autres problèmes à
traiter
dit autrement dans un monde en
croissance comme disait paraît-il
francis boy il n'y a pas de mauvais
manager vraiment dans croissance il n'y
a pas de mauvais manager au pied du mur
que vous reconnaissez les bons or la
classe politique qu'on a aujourd'hui a
été forgée dans un monde en croissance
donc ya pas de bons première
approximation il n'y en a pas j'ai été
touchée quand j'ai fait mon cours à
l'état il ya quand même un élève s'était
barré étrangers je pense en l'occurrence
plutôt qu'il a osé poser une question
que ses copains on va poser à la fin
d'un cours de cette nature il dit mais
est ce que les politiques sont au
courant à lennart j'ai trouvé ça
délicieux et je dis pas non pour être au
courant faut suivre un cours c'est pas
parce que vous donnez ministre aux
députés que vous avez suivi un cours
vous avez été élu mais vous n'avez pas
suivi un cours puis une fois vous êtes
élu vous n'avez pas le temps d'en suivre
donc le donc c'est ça le sujet c'est
comment j'aurais partie d'efforts
comment j'aurais partie l'effort juste
ça donc dans un monde sans croissance
toute augmentation à l'ancienneté
garantie du chômage ailleurs
comment vous traitez ça comment vous
traitez ça compliqué donc vous n'avez
que des effets d'éviction dans un monde
sans croissance
alors ça c'est évident encore une fois
la dynamique des systèmes est capable de
vous le quantifier ce truc là mais bon
courage avant que cette dynamique des
systèmes la haye infuser des politiques
publiques de mon vivant je pense que je
le verrais pas voilà je vais finir avec
une petite note d'humour
vous avez ici un petit calcul que je
vous livre sur les gens qui disent tous
ça c'est des conneries on s'en fout
l'espace est immense monsieur elon musk
a dit qu'on allait vivre sur mars
donc tout ça c'est des conneries on a
des planètes de rechange vous avez ici
un engin minier un peu particulier qui
la fusée saturn 5
pourquoi c'est un engin minière peu
particulier parce qu'on a un taux
d'avant envoyé sur la lune alors avec
quelques mineurs qui saperait buzz
aldrin et neil armstrong et ses mineurs
bien payés compris quelques risques en
mai et ils sont revenus avec un peu de
minerais donc les envoyer là dedans ça a
coûté 120 milliards de dollars qui sont
revenus avec 400 kg de minerai
donc vous pouvez aller mines et les
astéroïdes
avec cette technologie là ça vous coûte
300 milliards de dollars la tonne de
minerai alors admettons qu'on fasse des
progrès avec des robots etc
je veux bien qu'on gagne un facteur 100
enfin 3 milliards de dollars la tonne de
minerai versus le fait qu'une tonne de
minerai de fer c'est 50 ou 100 dollars
je pas très confiant sur le fait qu'on
va pouvoir maintenir une utilisation
industrielle avec ça si vous voulez
voilà et enfin je vais finir avec un
tout petit couplet sur démocratie et
systèmes élus versus entreprises
je vous le dis pourquoi parce que en
fait j'ai mis longtemps c'est je vous le
redis mon âge je suis très lent et j'ai
mis longtemps avant de comprendre que
les gens à qui je parlais - inclus ce
que je me parle à moi même je m'entends
en fait on avait des réflexes ce que
vous savez on fait confiance à nos sens
sont nés les animaux après tout hein
on avait très souvent des réflexes qui
étaient issus de notre expérience
professionnelle immédiate
or les gens à qui je parle
sauf exception ne sont pas dans le monde
politique ne pourrait jamais
d'intervention dans le monde politique
quand j'ai dans le monde politique ça
des élus en fait très peu donc je fais
des interventions devant des gens qui
quand ils travaillent travaillent dans
des entreprises et dans des
administrations
donc c'est des gens qui travaillent dans
un système hiérarchisé d'accord dans une
entreprise et une administration il ya
un chef
voilà donne des instructions et puis il
ya des collaborateurs et ils appliquent
les instructions donc si on dit aux
salariés de l'ademe vous allez vous
occuper de ce cas dans les poubelles
il ne s'occupe pas de lui même
d'ailleurs regardez comment on fait pour
vendre plus de cerfs-volants il fait pas
ça d'accord et si on lui dit votre
bureau est arrangé de lui-même il va pas
s'installer à lille et si on lui dit le
travail démarre à 9 heures du matin que
lui même qui se met pas à travailler à 3
heures du matin jusqu'à 6 heures il
s'arrête après donc vous avez un chef
le chef a les moyens de faire respecter
des instructions à leurs vieilles un
fonctionnaire c'est un peu plus
compliqué pour les gars disent est ce ça
marche en ce qui concerne l'entreprise
privée bas vous avez quelqu'un qui
refuse d'exécuter les ordres c'est prévu
dans le code du travail vous foutez la
porte
donc ya pas de sujet et il ya des moyens
de faire respecter les instructions pour
de vrai et alors du coup le réflexe de
tous les gens qui entendent l'exposé de
ce genre de problème c'est de dire mais
que fait la police
un policer lui qu'est-ce qui fait c'est
le chef
après tout bah non le problème c'est pas
le problème c'est que c'est un exécuteur
testamentaire de tous les gens qui ont
voté pour lui non eux puis e puis e puis
e -e
donc en fait ce type là il décide de
rien du tout il arbitre il est dans un
système de flux remontant
contradictoires et là dedans je vous ai
pas encore mis le medef qui dit virez
moi des charges sociales pendant qu la
cgt vous dis moi je veux qu'on en
rajoute
et c'est enfin je veux dire il passe son
temps à recevoir des injonctions
contradictoires
donc qu'est-ce qui fait il arbitre en
fonction de la moindre nuisance
c'est très exactement ce que fait un élu
il arbitre en fonction de la moindre
nuisance
donc les gens qui gueulent le plus fort
ou plus exactement les gens qui ont le
plus de pouvoir de nuisance gagne et je
vais vous donner une expérience
personnelle là dessus j'ai été un
compagnon de route de la vie nicolas
hulot à l'époque du pacte écologique
à cette époque là nicolas est un certain
nombre de lits briouze dans mon genre
réfléchissent à des trucs alors on en
était en plus on a fait du chemin quand
même en disant à des trucs qu'on pouvait
proposer sa dot donc le pacte qui sort
avec un certain nombre de mesures qu'on
propose avoir quelqu'un et puis tout le
monde s'en fout royalement les candidats
ne signe pas jusqu'au jour où elodie je
songe à me présenter aux élections et
alors seulement les candidats dit oh
[ __ ] s'il se présente 10 % 10 % il
fait le deuxième tour où je signe donc
le premier à signer ces verrous une
passe que berrou il a besoin de se
différencier il est au centre et l'eau
quelque part occupe ce terrain là haut
niveau de l'électorat de la sensibilité
électorale une fois que béraud a signé
royal est coincée elle est obligée de
signer et une fois qu royal acier
sarkozy est coincé il est obligé de
signer et de cette époque là soit dit en
passant sarkozy avoue une aide féroce à
hulot comme il voit une haine féroce à
tous les gens qui l'avaient obligé à
plier donc il est pas du tout aller
signer de pactes de gaieté coeur il est
allé le signer parce que il était
électoralement coincé il ya sept ans moi
j'ai fondé le chiffre project je suis un
illustre inconnu
si je dis retenez moi ou je me présente
aux élections présidentielles je pense
que je peux concurrencer coluche mais je
ferai sûrement pas 10%
enfin je peux concurrencer coluche pour
faire rigoler les gens je veux dire mais
je ferai pas 10%
donc qu'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
on a essayé de faire de la dynamique des
systèmes qu'on a essayé faire des
calculs intelligent disant votre
politique s'en fout comme de l'an 40
il s'en fout comme de l'an 40 lui l'on
inclut du reste depuis qu'il est
ministre
foucault voilà et en plus si je
limite au domaine qui nous intéresse ça
qui m'intéresse moi l'énergie vous avez
des gens qui sont absolument contre tous
y compris donc en fait dans le domaine
de l'énergie vous êtes exactement d'un
domaine du changement climatique
exactement comme dans les autres
domaines des tas de gens qui gueulent
pour et le contre et c'est et personne
n'est d'accord sur rien voilà donc bon
courage parce que je pense que la
politique publique se contrefout de la
dynamique des systèmes alors je vais
quand même finir par un truc qui est
plus optimiste que ça en démocratie je
le redis le système et remontant qui ne
se fout pas de la dynamique des systèmes
les corps intermédiaires serre que les
seules catégories qui ont deux heures de
temps pour écouter des raisonnements
compliqué et essayer de se les
approprier
c'est absolument pas les élus qui en
trente secondes pour arbitrer des
conflits
rappelez vous de ce que disait michel
rocard qui est pourtant un type
absolument génial il disait premier
ministre c'est un boulot absolue mois
horribles vous devez décider toutes les
deux minutes sur un sujet auquel vous
avez rien compris c'est dans ses
mémoires et dans ses mémoires
non mais ce type était géniale dur et
c'est pour ça à mon avis qui n'est
jamais devenu président n'était pas
assez d mahbod pour ça et donc en termes
de politiques publiques avoir de
l'influencé directement sur un élu par
sa seule intelligence
je suis désolé de vous désespérez ça
n'existe pas par contre par sa seule
intelligence avoir de l'influencé sur
des corps intermédiaires qui eux mêmes
vont pouvoir rassembler des forces qui
feront pression sur les élus
ça c'est possible donc je vais finir
cette intervention en disant ceci que
sera utile non pas s'il tente d'infuser
directement le monde politique avec des
idées intelligentes que ça sert à rien
mais s'ils tendent infuser le monde des
corps intermédiaires avec des idées
intelligentes et là vous allez avoir un
problème parce que vous êtes comme tous
vos petits copains qui dépendent du
pouvoir politique
si les choses intelligentes que vous
avez envie de dire sans trop orthogonale
à la démagogie du moment vous n'y
arriverez pas c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu
deux rapports sur 100 % web d'air qui
sont sortis avec des calculs ni fait ni
à faire quand vous regarder dans le
détail tout simplement parce que c'est
ça qu'on a envie d'entendre en ce moment
et donc c'est ça qui sort
je pourrais vous citer plein plein
d'exemples plein d'exemples je peux vous
dire par exemple qu'en ce moment ci au
sein de rte
vous souhaitez émettre des réserves sur
la pertinence du scénario 50% de
nucléaire y compris sur l'objectif du
risque nucléaire
moi je fais partie des gens qui disent
que ça va l'augmenter les deux pages sur
mon site avait à dire si ça vous amuse
je pense que ça va l'augmenter sera
produite le bcsa veulent augmenter et
bien c'est pas possible parce qu'il ya
un mec qui s'appelle brottes qui a fait
voter la loi des 50% de nucléaire et
donc son problème d'ego et supérieur à
l'intérêt du pays
non mais c'est pas une blague c'est un
drame donc c'est ce que je disais bon
courage si vous souhaitez voilà faut pas
le dire trop fort voilà c'est mon
conseil si vous avez des choses
intelligentes à dire de les dites pas
trop fort faut un fusée les corps
intermédiaires bas bruit ces derniers
merci aux journalistes que nous
applaudir merci
à
on
[Musique]
e
à
on
et
des souhaits des minutes les sous ni
limites de la démocratie ou haider
consommer le temps de parole qui était
attribué à la salle ce qui est une bonne
illustration
[Rires]
ils étaient quelques questions jean marc
jancovici sur certains points de son
intervention lors été orientée très
énergie on va être un peu plus
ressources les deux étant liés mais dans
le cadre de la table ronde
oui alors qu'ils étaient micro je sais
pas si loin que le micro arrive en fait
l'énergie
enfin la ressource et au premier ordre
une question d'énergie si je creuse sous
la terre là ici je vais trouver dans un
mètre cube de terre les 92 éléments du
tableau de mendeleïev donc c'est juste
une affaire d'énergie il arrivait à les
extraire et à les purifier donc au
premier ordre sauf pour les ressources
biologiques parce que ça toute l'énergie
du monde ne refait pas le code génétique
du tigre mais sauf pour les ressources
biologiques pour toutes les ressources
minérales c'est au premier rang une
question d'énergie
bonjour merci beaucoup mais qui a les
bras je dirige une agence locale de
l'énergie peut-être qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses dans votre conférence est s'est
toujours aussi brillant mais par rapport
à l'île de france le concept de retour
d'énergie reçue sur l'énergie investie
parce que c'est une des problématiques
en ile-de-france évidemment qui
importent 100 % de son énergie de ces
matériaux qui exploite 100 % de ces
déchets est peut-être revenir sur un
bout de votre conférence pour expliquer
ça c'est à dire on peut se payer des
hôpitaux a dû 14 points et on est les
agrocarburants aujourd'hui sont sûres du
1 point pour un et donc on va pas y
arriver avec ses solutions et c'est ce
que j'ai expliqué là là et là en gros la
possibilité de dégager du temps et des
ressources pour faire des choses qui ne
sont pas strictement alimentaire dépend
du fait que vous avez déjà satisfait les
fonctions vitales de la population avec
simplement une fraction de la population
qui s'en occupe une autre manière de le
dire c'est que la quantité de services
que vous pouvez offrir à la population
est une fonction inverse de la quantité
de personnes qui travaillent dans
système énergétique
donc en fait plus vous augmentez le
nombre de gens qui travaillent dans le
système énergétique et moins vous aurez
de services à offrir à la population ce
qui est pas nécessairement un drame en
soi mais il faut le savoir
donc vous avez la possibilité d'avoir du
temps long pour former des médecins
parce que les médecins ont par ailleurs
leur nourriture assurée par d'autres
sans qu'ils aient besoin de s'en occuper
leur logement assuré par d'autres sans
qu'ils aient besoin de s'en occuper
leurs vêtements assurée par d'autres
sans qu'ils aient besoin de s'en occuper
et c'est donc dans une logique de
dynamique des systèmes effectivement
vous avez besoin d'avoir une forte
productivité des travaux sur la matière
pour que vous puissiez libérer du temps
pour former des gens qui vont vous
offrir des services beaucoup plus basé
sur la connaissance que basé sur la
matière manipuler stricto sensu
alors il ya effectivement des gens qui
considèrent que un bon proxy de la
quantité de services que vous pouvez
offrir à la population c'est ça la
pyramide de maslow c'est le fameux
euroise du système énergétique
c'est-à-dire la quantité d'énergie que
vous extrayez de l'environnement pour
faire fonctionner le système énergétique
lui-même alors le sauf que rien que
définir correctement ce que c'est que
l'euro y est un débat de spécialistes
qui prend très longtemps ils trouvent
que le chiffre a co organisé une école
de physique aux houches qui était
totalement dédié à cette histoire
maintenant deux ans donc c'était juste
un prétexte pour aller en face du mont
blanc pendant une semaine de mars et
donc ce qu'on a fait à ce moment là
c'est qu'on a essayé déjà de se mettre
d'accord sur les frontières du système
parce que quand vous extrayez un baril
de pétrole de terre vous pouvez dire
leur os x et l'énergie que j'ai utilisée
pour extraire le pétrole sur l'énergie
extraite
mais vous pouvez là dedans ajouté
l'énergie du raffinage parce que vous
utilisez pas le pétrole brut pourrait
rajouter l'énergie du transport
vous pouvez rajouter l'énergie qui est
utilisé pour fabriquer les engins de
forage les bateaux la raffinerie et ses
bons donc vous avez un sujet de
frontières du système qui est un vrai
sujet de débat pas complètement et or
pour qualifier un héros ni globale du
système énergétique vous avez besoin de
nous mettre d'accord là dessus donc
c'est pour ça que cette pyramide de
maslow n est pas nécessairement on
comprend le concept le concept c'est
plus en gros vous arrivez à extraire de
l'énergie de l'environnement avec peu de
moyens et plus vous allez vivre dans une
société d'abondance
c'est sale c'est 50 donc moi je les
relis autrement en expliquant pourquoi
on était passé des renouvelables aux
fossiles mais c'est quelque part ça
reflète sa et al'inverse dans une
société totalement agraire vous n'avez
pas la possibilité d'avoir du temps pour
former les médecins et la sagesse est
partagé entre tous le monde quelque part
donc vous avez des remèdes simples à
utiliser à base de plantes partagé entre
tous bondés vous n'avez pas de trucs
beaucoup plus sophistiqué que ça qui
demande une spécialisation de
quelques-uns donc c'est très clair pour
moi que la décroissance des flux
énergétiques aura notamment un impact
sur la quantité de trucs qu'on peut
soigner
c'est ce qui me pousse à dire dans les
choses un peu cynique que j'affirme
parfois que aujourd'hui dans un contexte
de décroissance énergétique investir
beaucoup de moyens pour maintenir les
très vieux en vie c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas équitable
quand les très vieux bear river puis
voilà je veux dire on meurt tous un jour
oui monsieur oui bonjour je ne sais pas
si je m'entendais bien amer donc en fait
moi je suis venu avec d'autres personnes
du mouvement des villes en transition
fait aussi partie des amis de la terre
une des ong qui visiblement vous poser
problème en 2009 et je suis aussi
designer écologique une approche du
design pas très répandu en france
alors je vais juste faire une remarque
quand même parce que la systémique
il ya différents sites manière de
traiter la systémique
sauf que là on en a parlé en filigrane
la systémique ça peut être une vision
comptable c'est comme ce que j'appelle
l'écologie excellent c'est ainsi on se
focalise sur le co2 qui est un sujet
important et il ya beaucoup de choses en
représentation que je trouve tout à fait
intéressante il ya des choses que je ne
partage pas n'est ce pas grave on est on
est on n'a pas le temps d'en discuter
maintenant mais je veux dire je vais
faire un raccourci puisque là-bas
beaucoup de temps en fait pour parler
d'écologie de fichiers excel c'est dire
que par exemple un arbre ça va permettre
de gérer tant et tant de co2 mais un
arbre ça cache une forêt puisque en
écologie un arbre c'est qu'une partie
d'un écosystème dont ça arrivera aussi
dans les présentations temps en temps le
faire sentir
il faut comprendre comment fonctionnent
les forêts et pas simplement parler de
la quantité de co2 yann je pense que là
il
un vrai enjeu fondamental aussi de
pédagogie sur assister nicolas sanhes
apparaît absolument pas dans une
présentation
je pense que ça manque de choses
incarnez vivante voilà et du coup il ya
des choses que effectivement on peut
affirmer de manière plus simple mais qui
dès qu'ils mériteraient d bah ouais
c'est juste un feedback radical merci
eric m'a vu donc si ce n'est pas une
question je suis pas d'accord avec une
partie ce qui a été dit me suis pas de
questions et de remarques ou questions
oui monsieur n'hésitez pas à disposition
bonjour à tous donc je suis ingénieur à
l'ademe mais citoyen par ailleurs
je vous remercie pour évidemment vos
interventions j'ai quand même une super
c'est une question que je pas si vous
répondrai en fait la famille c'est pas
une question non enfin je peux mais on
va juste dans la famille des énergies
renouvelables puisque c'est pas
qu'aujourd'hui mais vous connaît depuis
déjà un certain temps et à vous lire
également
on sent qu'il y a derrière les énergies
renouvelables un certain nombre de
questions vous vous posez qui sont
légitimes mais il ya un amalgame
à mon sens important entre l'électricité
renouvelable et la chaleur renouvelable
oui et en fait vous mettez dans une aide
dans l'énergie renouvelable ensemble des
familles en en traitant et aujourd'hui
vous l'avez fait est ce vraiment non
l'ennemi mais laissez moi parler s'il
vous plaît ne yo yo je leur ai juste et
remis à la question et vous l'avez fait
aujourd'hui quand vous avez parlé
d'énergie renouvelable vous avez parler
exclusivement de l'éolien et du
photovoltaïque vous avez parlé du vent
et du soleil
et quand vous parlez du salé vous parlez
du photovoltaïque sur lequel il ya
certainement un certain nombre de
problèmes mais ça serait intéressant
peut-être aussi de réfléchir à l'aune de
la chaleur renouvelable et des
ressources mobilisables localement il ya
des ressources si les particularités
régionales notamment en ile de france et
est le sujet du jour
il ya peut-être aussi à faire la
distinction entre l'électricité et la
chaleur renouvelable ce que les enjeux
ne sont pas les mêmes les modalités de
mobilisation ne sont pas les mêmes les
bilans énergétiques globaux conversion
énergie primaire énergie finale sont pas
les mêmes je pense que ça vaudrait
peut-être de les distinguer dans vos
propos alors je vais quand même répondre
en plus que si c'est parce que c'est
vraiment marque quand je vous ai montré
ça j'ai insisté sur le fait qu' on
confondait énergie électricité en
permanence pour crois que j'ai
exactement fait ce que vous me reprochez
de ne pas avoir fait sur ce graphique ça
c'est renouvelable
sauf que une partie n'est déjà plus
renouvelable pascal la déforestation là
dedans l'hydroélectricité est
parfaitement individualisé et là c'est
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
c'est particulier c'est tout à fait
explicites et dans la légende
quand j'ai parlé des 100 milliards mis
en france j'ai dit que c'était éolien et
solaire le gpad ici renouvelables je lis
et éolien et solaire donc je crois que
j'ai été raisonnablement précis sur ce
que j'ai désigné
et oui je maintiens que aujourd'hui met
l'essentiel de notre pognon dans le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien
est une erreur majeure ça aggrave le
problème
oui je suis d'accord
non mais j'ai pas en train de dire ce
qu'il fallait faire je suis juste en
train de dire m 100 milliards sur
l'éolien et le photovoltaïque est un
truc qui n'a pas de sens en france se
disent que ça que j'ai dit alors non non
non non non non non non effectivement
prenant justement c'est mieux peut-être
que je prenne le micro en main pour le
coup ce que je dis c'est qu'à 7
milliards sur terre vous aurez pas que
de la chaleur renouvelable et que de
l'hydro électricité pour faire vivre
tout le monde avec 30000 avec caviar de
pib mondial ça n'est d'accord mais son
geste juste auquel il est peut être
pertinent quand vous annoncer les
chiffres et quand vous avez un discours
de modération de l'intérêt des énergies
renouvelables de distinguer l'évaluation
ne vous en faites sur la production
d'électricité renouvelable et vous venez
de leur faire parce que vous reparler de
photovoltaïque et éolien et la
production de chaleur renouvelable je
pense qu'elles n'ont pas les même destin
ils n'ont pas les mêmes ambitions ne
sont pas les intérêts non plus j'avais
déjà payé contraire question je m'engage
à vous messieurs c'est dans les modèles
chez il y en a un qu'il y en a qui
changera la pac à la marche et la
démographie
parce que c'est le premier problème
à la base de tout le reste si on aime on
a après il faut faire des règles de
trois mois j'adore avec 2 3 qui
s'appelle l'équation de kaya de 3 et qui
permet de vent fait je ne sais pas si
vous savez mais depuis qu'on a commencé
à développer les nerfs dans le monde
solaire éolien et hydroélectricité parce
que l'essentiel de l'accroissement aux
nerfs sur les cinq ou dix dernières
années c'est l'hydroélectricité c'est
pas du solaire du oui il se trouve que
dans le même temps on a eu les sort des
centrales à charbon en chine et le
contenu moyen d'un kilowattheures
d'énergie utilisé sur terre le contenu
moyen en co2 a augmenté sur les 15
dernières années pas de beaucoup mais un
peu quand même
donc on parlait d'arbres et de forêts
tout à l'heure voilà typiquement un truc
qui masque la forêt gens regardent se
dit il à la presse nous parle d'un truc
qui est à une vue partielle du système
moi ce que j'ai simplement rappeler ici
c'est que ça c'est pas ça et que les
gens qui disent qu'on va faire de la
croissance verte il pense que ça ça va
remplacer ça dans les 30 ans qui
viennent
bon moi je dis non moi je dit
l'essentiel du problème si on veut tenir
dans la boîte
il est dans la contraction des flux et
j'ai osé dire un truc très peu de
partisans du solaire et de l'éolien 10g
10,2 degrés c'est une récession
il y en a combien qui le disent dans les
partisans du solaire à l'éolien
ils sont tous riches qu'il y un saut je
connais quasiment tous c'est à dire on
va faire ça et en même temps on va avoir
la croissance du pib donc ils sont
pas du tout cohérent non plus dans ce
qui est enfin moi je pense l'être sont
pas du tout cohérent parce qu'il raconte
voilà donc je suis donc après le
potentiel de nerfs en ile de france
il est réelle comme il est réel dans
beaucoup d'autres endroits sur la
chaleur je suis un grand partisan des
pompes à chaleur et si au lieu de mettre
100 milliards dans l'éolien et le
solaire
on avait mis 100 milliards dans ce pays
dans les pompes à chaleur on pouvait
payer une pompe à chaleur gratos à 10
millions de ménages
c'est à dire qu'on aurait débarrasser la
france de son fuel et d'une bonne partie
et de l'essentiel de son chauffage à gaz
on aurait supprimé 25% des émissions de
co2 dans le pays on aurait supprimé 15
milliards d'euros d'importations parents
d'accord donc pourquoi on l'a pas fait
tout simplement parce que les gens qui
sont vocaux sur la question de l'énergie
font très exactement ce que vous me
reprocher d'avoir fait alors je le fais
pas ils ne s'intéressent qu'à
l'électricité et il s'intéresse qu'au
nucléaire
donc ils ont poussé les subventions aux
énergies renouvelables électriques ayant
vécu de l'intérieur tous les débats
énergétique qu'on a eu depuis 2003 je
peux vous dire que c'est très exactement
ce qu'ils ont fait avec le soutien
implicite des gaziers il est question le
public dynamique alors des dynamiques
qui s'enclenche oui est-ce qu'elles sont
à l'échelle du problème non réponse et
cadets dynamique et qu'elles sont pas à
l'échelle du problème
voilà les deux dents dans l'est alors je
le redis ce qu'on m'a reproché tout à
l'heure c'est à dire de me focaliser sur
le solaire et l'éolien c'est pourtant ce
qui est en train de se passer pour
l'essentiel des débats sur la transition
un peu partout quand on parle de la
transition dans les territoires ils
rêvent tous de devenir autonome en
énergie et en fait quand il vous dit ça
c'est je veux produire chez moi de
l'éolien et du solaire est la raison
pour laquelle ils sont très intéressés à
le faire c'est que ça ramène d euros en
même temps que ça permet de tenir un
discours sympa donc ses services
la fiscalité oui ça ramène surtout de la
fiscalité parce que c'est parce que
c'est pas des emplois locaux quand on
vient à ériger des éoliennes dans votre
champ c'est pas des mecs de votre
commune qui vont le faire
par contre ça vous ramène de l'impôt de
la contribution foncière des entreprises
fa oui donc jacques très content donc le
dans les dynamiques intéressantes sur ce
genre de sujet en fait je vais vous
étonner mais ce que je vois aujourd'hui
de plus cohérence vient plutôt du monde
de l'entreprise
les deux choses que vous avez vues qui
sont ces éléments je vais alors je vais
donner quelques exemples
mais ça va peut-être aller chercher dans
des domaines qui vont vous trouve que
c'est pas exactement l'aménagement
l'aménagement francilien
il se trouve que à titre personnel en
carbone 4 travail peu avec les
collectivités locales à cause d'un truc
s'appelle les appels d'offres parce que
évaluer le rapport qualité prix quand
vous faites des appels d'offres c'est
infaisable donc
nous on sait traiter des problèmes
compliqués en discutant pendant 150 ans
avec le client pour savoir comment on va
le prendre c'est un foutu de faire ça
dans le cadre d'un appel d'offres sauf
sauf exception on travaille pas beaucoup
puis après vous avez une question c'est
moins cher et moins cher et le moins
cher qui gagne donc comme on embauche
des gens qui ont fait des études
supérieures plus tôt du haut du panier
on a une structure de coûts qui permet
il ya des prix de marché on peut pas y
échapper
qui permet absolument pas de répondre
dans les gammes de prix auquel on
n'essaye pas mais pour ce que j'en vois
a vu de l'extérieur en discutant avec
des gens à droite et à gauche et ses
dents dans les collectivités locales on
a quand même une reproduction à petite
échelle de ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure sur la dichotomie entre le
discours électoral et la réalité de
terrain
donc en général on board le système aux
frontières de telle sorte que l'on
puisse dire que ce qu'on a fait il vient
me fait plutôt le truc à l'envers pour
dire que le truc et bien on adapte la
frontière du système tel que paris
neutre en carbone ça arrivera le jour où
paris ne dépendra plus des touristes
japonais qui vient dans l'avion
peut-être je ne sais pas des touristes
chinois non plus les grands magasins
d'autres en carbone ça arrive voir le
jour où il y aura pas un chinois je peux
vous dire j'ai travaillé mon bureau est
juste derrière vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
les galeries lafayette et le printemps
sans chinois ils ont quelques soucis
avec leur chiffre d'affaires par
ailleurs je peux vous dire que sans co2
fabriquer le métal des montres gucci etc
et ce en méthane fabriquer le cuir des
sacs à main vuitton ça va être compliqué
donc
très sympathique comme discours moi je
suis très pour que l'on dise on va faire
un exercice justement un exercice de
nature à peu scolaire mais qui a
énormément d'utilité pour comprendre
comment le système fonctionne et est
asservi donc qu'on dise on va jouer en
chambre à paris notre en carbone pour
voir ce que ça donne ça je suis tout à
fait pour
par contre comment c'est à dire paris
sera neutre en carbone en 2050
heureusement qu'il a lot sera morte
parce que
auquel sera parti depuis longtemps c'est
évident que ça n'arrivera pas avec
l'activité actuelle de paris et que ça
n'existera jamais enfin je veux dire non
donc il ya donc on retrouve dans les
collectivités locales donc plus elles
ont des moyens de regarder loin plus
être sont grosses et plus elles sont
grosses populations dans la démagogie
électorale inversement quand vous êtes
maire d'une commune de 80 personnes
c'est où la démagogie électorale est un
truc qui est plus compliqué parce que
vous connaissez tous se lèvent tous vos
électeurs par le nom donc c'est une
alchimie différentes qui fait office est
plutôt un sacerdoce un de devenir mère
dans une commune de 80 personnes donc
l'alchimie électorale et pas du tout la
même
et vous avez en général des trucs qui
sont à la fois moins vantard et quelque
part moins ambitieux donc dans le camp
je n'avais pas lu mais donc le donc mais
dans les entreprises
il se passe des trucs intéressants et je
vais vous donner quelques exemples on aa
carbone 4 en ce moment un client
n'aurait pas qui mais une grosse boîte
dont le directeur de la stratégie nous a
commandé une étude sur qu'est ce que je
fais dans un monde qui est globalement
récession longue structurelles d'accord
racontez moi ce que devient mon fils que
peut devenir mon business
j'ai pas vu ça dans une collectivité
locale c'est à dire qu'une collectivité
locale qui nous demanderait racontez moi
ce que je fais quand mon budget est
devenue la moitié de ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
j'attends encore la deuxième chose
deuxième exemple que je peux vous vous
donnez c'est il ya des il ya des
entreprises qui aujourd'hui organise de
la sobriété tout ce qui est colocation
c'est de l'organisation de sobriété
parce que vous diminuer les surfaces
habitables par personne par rapport au
fait d'avoir un logement sol parce que
vous mutualiser la salle de bains vont
mutualiser la cuisine à vous monsieur
zier les couloirs ou mais très rarement
donc vous avez voilà deux exemples juste
deux exemples dans pour montrer qu'il
peut y avoir des trucs qui sont très
intéressants en dehors de la politique
de la politique publique telle qu'on
al'habitude de la pensée alors c'est
encore parcellaires ceux qui bougent
aujourd'hui c'est le temps que les gens
acceptent de consacrer au sujet donc ça
si vous voulez un facteur multiplicatif
un peu significatif à vous mettre sous
la dent pour dire quand même j'observe
quelque chose qui est pas juste et si
laudic c'est le temps que les gens
acceptent de consacrer à commencer à
comprendre ce qui peut se passer
dans ce domaine là par contre si vous
allez à l'étape d'après qui sont les
moyens consacrés
moi j'ai pas encore vu aujourd'hui une
collectivité locale disant je vais
embaucher
donc je sais pas combien de personnes on
contrôle de gestion de la mairie de
paris mais enfin on va dire quelques
euros et seris comptable on va dire
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
et qu'on compte le co2 ou les arbres ou
les pucerons ou et c'est parce que moi
je suis d'accord il faut compter plein
de trucs pour le moment j'ai pas vu que
l'on ai dit qu'on allait embaucher 500
personnes pour faire ce genre de
comptabilité et s'en servir dans le
coeur des décisions qu'on va faire
derrière donc l'allocation des moyens
est absolument parfaite
bon alors on pourrait dire oui mais on a
de moins en moins de pognon confère ce
que je viens de raconter aux idées
d'accord mais enfin il est prévu qu'ils
sont plus importants que d'autres
donc peut-être que dans le contexte que
je viens de donner les merdes de chiens
c'est moins important que de mettre un
peu de jus de cerveau dans ce sujet là
pour savoir comment on évite les émeutes
peut-être donc aujourd'hui j'ai pas vu
l'allocation des moyens qui va en face
de l'ampleur du problème à traiter et
c'est également vrai dans les
entreprises c'est à dire que carbone 4
qui revendique d'être un des plus gros
cabinets comptables sur la question
énergie climat
ce que m'a dit il parlait que de co2 non
j'ai parlé que d'énergie essentiellement
donc j'ai parlé que plus physique le
mais qui est un des plus gros cabinets
comptables du co2 donc des flux
physiques sur la place de paris on est
40 le plus gros cabinet comptable sur la
place de paris c ou deloitte où il
voyageait pas quoi ils sont ils sont
débiles
bon donc pour le moment il ya une
asymétrie de moyens entre je compte ce
que jean baptiste hausse elle nous a dit
de conter et je compte le monde physique
dont on dépend qui est massive
absolument massive fait ce soir il ya
des divisions pouvaient sortir ça si
vous êtes assez faisait davantage
d'espacé
c'est important pour espérer progresser
il ya dans mes trois quilles juste en
glissant qui est sorti en édition poche
chez odile jacob qui sont ici en
éditeurs vont gagner se chiffrerait dont
on entendra parler en découle est en
cours de la présentation des carmes aux
nombreuses propositions donc l'europe
change d'air quillan nouvel ouvrage
si vous êtes de près a dit cassé
absolument